e
oui et
source
les excuses de la sncf pour le travail
est ici un peu en retard mais enfin je
pense que ça ira en fasse des excuses de
tous les automobilistes qui s'empare
dans les bouchons s'il tentait qu'ils
aient une invention de venir je vais
essayer de vous présenter en peu de
temps beaucoup trop de choses
alors comme je suis un bon bah je vais
pour une fois commencez par vous
présenter des conclusions puisque je
vais vous raconter
et puis après comme ça ça permettra de
couper d'entraînement les explications
si je suis pris par le temps alors les
conclusions que le d'essayer de vous
livrer ce soir
en voici quelques-unes la première c'est
que si vous regardez c'est une des
choses que je vais essayer d'expliquer
comment a évolué le monde économique
depuis deux siècles
vous trouverez à l'origine de ce qui
s'est passé dans 95 % de l'énergie et 11
5% est un brillant ingénieur que votre
truc de cette nature donc dire autrement
l'essentiel de ce qui s'est passé sur
l'idée d'un des siècles s'explique par
fait que vont éprouver sur table
disponible en dix des treize entente est
assez facile à xbox
la deuxième chose importante que je vais
essayer de vous expliquer alors ça c'est
une pierre dans le jardin des
économistes c'est que en ce qui concerne
de l'énergie ce qui compte c'est pas des
bons prix malgré les cris d'orfraie d'un
certain monde industriel en ce moment
ses volumes en fait ce qui compte le
nombre de kilowattheures c'est pas
tellement le prix du kilowattheure
évidemment ceci va parfois avec ce
désinvestissement et à l'arrivée des
pompiers
la troisième chose que je vais vous
montrer et qui pour ceux d'entre vous
qui ont suivi le fameux d'emma nationale
qui a eu lieu en france
notre premier problème aujourd'hui en
grand c'est que l'approvisionnement
pétrolier et gazier est déjà orienté à
la baisse ça va continuer c'est un truc
qui l'arrachent du grand peuple est
occupé sauf marginalement monde
politique français dans l'aude ehva
qu'il a initié ce débat qui va d'une
promesse électorale ma vie sans grand
intérêt
est ce qu'ils tuent goût va nous arriver
à partir de maintenant c'est que le
paysage d'économie standard sarah six
ans alors je ne sais pas si le plan de
sauvetage des retraites veillette des
gens qui étaient en train d'être
discutées le vois comme d'habitude que
dans deux ans ont juré craché par terre
la croissance revient à prendre sans
tarder complètement exclue pour ces
championnats allemand le plan de
sauvetage des retraites à faire
aujourd'hui il sait avec une croissance
à 0 on voit plutôt un moins pas grand
chose
ceux ci l'avaient cela on a pendant
longtemps une impression que le temps de
répondre vous savez quand vous
grandissez de plus en plus fort
dangereux vous est donc dans deux ans ce
sera plus facile quand on est dans une
course contre la montre et l'averse qui
s'applique c'est à dire plus on attend
et plus la voiture est là et rentrer
dans le paradigme inverse que celui
qu'on avait jusqu'à maintenant c'était
un peu le temps joue contre nous et plus
on repousse plus en fête ou décident de
fait d'avoir la solution involontaire
qui s'applique et des choses
douloureuses qui s'applique aussi on
aura un peu technique dans la manière
dont il faut s'adapter à la situation
beaucoup d'autres journées là aussi en
france on aime bien voir éditer cliquer
partout et penser que ça va être tout
l'espace puisque on veut qu'ils vont
trouver
oui ils vont contribuer un peu mais on
va surtout devoir pour tous creuser les
méninges et puis c'est la meilleure
formule 1 est sur les rails métalliques
une des choses également que je dirais
tu as faim c'est que changer le monde
pour le meilleur on va dire est
extrêmement avancées capitales
et c'est totalement irréaliste de penser
qu'on va y arriver que l'économie de
marché partout un des exemples on y
viendra
c'est que par exemple gérer la structure
de la production électrique en europe
avec toute l'électricité dans un grand
marché
je ne sais pas où ça nous mènera et
sûrement pas avec un tel sens
alors ce que je vais également vous
montrer c'est que en matière énergétique
de l'europe déjà d'eau pure dix autres
autrement
l'urgence c'est maintenant qu'on
reprendra ce moment campagne et c'est
paradoxalement en et vante même coup de
chance si on sait la saisir parce que
vous savez que les grandes réalisations
souvent en face grand défi donc le vent
défilent tout de suite et si l'on sait
répondre on sait là paradoxalement
comprend les meilleures options de se
retrouver très bien gardés pour aider
d'autres pays qui devront faire quelque
chose pour le climat de se lancer dans
ce genre de cas mais ça demande
cependant quelques petites choses là
aussi je vais devenir la première c'est
qu'on traite des problèmes qui sont
correctement définis et par des
problèmes sur lesquels
voilà définition devant sa porte un
exemple bien tirés de l'actualité
récente
on a demandé aux français s'ils étaient
pour ou contre la transition énergétique
je suis sûr que si je demande à chacun
d'entre eux jouent devant une feuille a4
et de meubles de m'écrire en quelques
lignes ce que c'est pour vous la
transition énergétique et je récolte les
copies à la sortie là dans la salle sans
définition différente
alors moi je veux bien soufflé gens sur
un truc que personne n'a défini genre
pas tellement l'utilité de la chose
c'est très classique dans ces débats
c'est à dire que l'on fait délibérément
l'effort
surtout ne pas séparer et potions qui
son objectif explicite à bhl et chose
qui dépend de nos envies qualité
la deuxième chose qu'il faudra faire si
on a l'intention de sortir correctement
du problème que je vais vous exposer
c'est qu'il va falloir parler à la fois
plus et moins d'écologie
ça va il va falloir arrêter de regarder
avec la même dévotion dans l'ancien
temps de regarder les gens qui ouvraient
les mains concourir dans leurs
entrailles
elle va rater regarder les
macroéconomistes qu'historien n'importe
quoi tenir
par contre il va falloir mettre plus de
kiko économies dans la vierge le
problème dit autrement si l'on s'attaque
aux problèmes d'environnement a aidé vue
sentimental chasse premier peur c'est à
peu près sûr que l'on va faire des
choses qui ne correspond pas aux
problèmes internes et pour le moment on
fait aimer les mots no need a vu de quoi
être et on n'a pas assez d'emploi est-ce
et enfin il y aura pas de solution au
point que je vais exposer sans faire dé
pouvoir d'achat augmentation d'un quart
de point le champ de cette idée la bonne
question c'est quand
cher mais de toute façon les retraites
ont visé de toute façon d'achat va
baisser tout électrique
la bonne question encore une fois c'est
comment elles se ressemblent dans cet
espace
enfin on arrive quand même à trouver il
ressort tout fait qu'on a envie
d'avancer
on a quand même des projets qui nous
intéresse voilà maintenant qu'on va
passer au début de l'histoire et tout ça
je voulais dit au début on vient d'une
affaire d'énergie alors à revenir en ce
qui concerne l'énergie à une définition
c'est lequel un physique pas celle
qu'elle a dans les discours politiques
et l'énergie en physique elle a une
définition très précise
elle caractérise le changement d'état du
monde vous savez que l'énergie en
physique c'est la grandeur caractérise
le changement d'état d'un système donc
autrement dit il ya des filières
d'énergie quelque part par le monde qui
nous entoure change un certain nombre
d'exemples sont faciles à constater on
va dire quand vous n'avez température
qui chante quelque part eh bien quelle
énergie qui entrent en jeu ce soit pour
chauffer ou refroidir une pièce quand
vous avez dit et ce qui change
vous avez de l'énergie tirent en jeu là
aussi que ce soit pour en accélérer ou
ralentir quand vous avez les formes qui
change
vous avez de l'énergie qui entrent en
jeu quand vous avez compositions
chimiques ich habe vous avez de
l'énergie qu'un jeu et c'est tout ce que
je vous affiche maintenant c'est des
vérifications du monde qui nous entoure
surtout la dernière ou de l'énergie
entrent en jeu et set énergique quand
ici le degré de changement qui est
interdit donc compter l'énergie
vous comptez le changement du monde
physique sais pas c'est exactement
pareil
première conclusion que je peux vous
livrez
de cette définition c'est que l'énergie
propre ne peut pas exister
par définition on peut pas exister
puisque avoir utilisé le d'énergie sert
à changer quelque chose et propre comme
vous savez ses rangs laisser les choses
en l'état
est ce que vous prenez dans les
toilettes le prix est un fort taux de
change donc laisser les choses en l'état
est propre
utiliser d'énergie avoir changé d
énergies propres s'établissent en
général
l'énergie propre certificat d énergie
qui sont utilisés avec des montants qui
sont tellement ridicule que les
avantages comme les inconvénients sont
ridicules aussi alors que vous y croire
parce que ça fera date avec enlevé en
général ça arrive et davantage en face
parce que ça porte sur l'équipement des
candidats 804 deuxième conclusion que je
sais que plus on modifie l'environnement
plus on utilise l'énergie par définition
plus on utilise l'énergie puisse pas de
choses autour d'eux est dû en
particulier vous allez créer d'effets
indésirables sont en général pour
mentionner vos modifications
il ya une loi qui est importante en
matière d'énergie qu'un certain nombre
d'entre vous vont le regarder en noir
douloureusement appris sur les bancs
d'école qui s'appelle la loi de
conservation d'énergie la conservation
des biens
quelque chose très simple elle vous dit
que quand vous avez affaire à un système
qui ne communiquent pas avec l'extérieur
la quantité d'énergie qui s'y trouve est
constante des bois pour le mans par une
fois que certains d'entre vous s'en rend
même si je prends la communauté des
hommes qui est un système si ce flou
mèche tchoutchou j'empêche la communauté
des hommes de communiquer avec le reste
de la planète
la communauté des hommes ne peut pas
disposer d'une énergie en décroissance
la seule manière pour les hommes d'avoir
plus d'énergie
c'est d'aller la chercher dans mon coeur
je vais vous reformuler ça autrement
l'homme les activités pour lui type des
hommes ne savent rien faire d'autre que
d'exploiter à leur conflit une énergie
qui existe déjà dans l'environnement
nous a pas prêté pour un an par les
nerfs même si on présente une promesse
électorale
tout ce qu'on voudrait c'est extraire de
l'environnement une énergie qui s'y
connaît alors l'énergie qu'on a droit
des experts de l'environnement ça fait
une énergie primaire quand c'est soit
quelque chose qui brûle pendant un temps
de charge de pétrole soit les lois du
disque à 102 par exemple des boyaux
difficile soit à d'ores et déjà en
mouvement de l'air de l'eau et sert à
tout ça s'appelle de l'énergie primaire
alors comme vous savez pas encore elle
non plus mettre les éclairages machine à
café
cette énergie binaire on va la
transformer pour en faire ce qu'on
appelle
hergé finale qui s est utilisé par les
machines innombrables utilisons
aujourd'hui et qui sont des carpes en
fils et électricité etc
quand vous passez de l'énergie qui mène
à l'énergie finale pour les pertes grâce
world gold a terminé avec cette énergie
finale général vous l'achetez moi le
plaisir moi ça valait fondamentalement
excités d'ajouter un litre d'essence en
kilowattheures d'électricité en général
me fait ça parce que ça vous rend
service et donc ce qu'il a vraiment vous
être utile en fait c'est l'énergie dit
qu utile pour acheter de l'énergie parce
que vous êtes intéressés par des degrés
les mouvements de la transformation de
charge tout le monde et c'est ça que je
veux un gars alors cette énergie dit il
vous l'avez à partir de l'énergie finale
à chaque fois vous avez des pertes alors
les pertes quand vous allez de l'énergie
primaire à l'énergie finale se vende
bien que consent dans une très bonne
ainsi pris par exemple soit pas inscrite
à quasiment 75 % c'est vous utilisez les
centrales à charbon kamprad en général
trois quarts de la chaleur pour chauffer
l'équivalent est passé de finale avait
dit vous avez aussi des pertes par
essence le moteur de la voiture que vous
utilisez en général il a un rendement de
conversion à peu près 20% entre
l'énergie thermique contenue dans
l'essence que vous achetez et l'énergie
cinétique de la voiture qui est
bizarrement il ya un débat qui est
toujours très diffus dans les esprits
quand on parle le gagner sur les pertes
en ce qui concerne l'efficacité de
l'engin monde utilisent il y aura des
matches très confus dans les esprits
entre efficacité et sobriété
alors je vais essayer de vous livrer
rapidement si vous avez une voiture
d'une tonne qui va de 5 300 à 3 litres
aux cent pour moi c'est ed cassidy
si vous avez lois tuent leurs rivales de
5 litres au cent à parler consent à face
en vue de l'assistance
ça c'est un cendrier c'est ma définition
et je vais un peu plus précis que ça si
vous passez volontairement d'une tonne à
6 ans qui noseda sobriété si vous passez
involontairement de une bonne assise
sans fil haut parce que vous n'arrivez
pas à boucler votre fringue moi c'est la
pauvreté ou décarie donc il ya trois
notions très proches en matière
d'énergie en mélangeant qu'à valence
l'efficacité de change dans le monde de
vie cinq ans au moins
la sauver et et change de mode de vie et
je le fais palières organisé délibéré
que ça pour ça - je change mon mode de
vie sous la barre 1 ça s'appelle la
pauvreté ou la carac ça me tombe dessus
le changer elle est encore une fois
l'été les productions c'est important de
distinguer alors maintenant on va passer
à l'ordre de grandeur qui justifie ce
que je vous ai raconté tout à l'heure
sur le fait que l'énergie ont tout fait
ou presque dans le monde qui nous
entoure
alors voici un touriste qui désole les
basques celui là plus breton de l'ancien
temps et notre touriste breton de
l'ancien temps s'en va avec son sac à
dos particulier on est sur le mont blanc
alors je crois pas qu'il atterrit sur
non pas un plafond à faire pour défendre
donc voici obélix parti pour monter sur
le pont blanc alors gelé un peu fait
décrire ce qui est un plus pour que ça
j'ai également fait maigrir celui d'hier
jeudi dès lors que ça comme ça j'ai
encaissé 100 kg
ainsi pour des calculs j'ai encore un
petit saison blanche nous avons dû faire
un boîtier dignement
alors je reprend je vous fais monter je
vais faire la moitié et a dénigré qui va
de chamonix haut du mont blanc avec un
gros sac sur le dos et aux jambes
il ya en faisant ça en luttant contre la
candidature de l'énergie mécanique que
vos jambes ont restitué
c'est un de kilowattheures donc je
prends une paire de jambes que je fais
travailler très dur pendant une journée
vous allez quand même transpirer en bout
en faisant ce genre de chose se désole
convaincu par exemple et vous fait de
garder leurs efforts
056 novateur admettons que vous soyez un
sporting bien entraînés et que vous
sachiez faire ça un jour sur deux ou un
jour sur trois est bien à la fin d'année
vous en restituer une énergie mécanique
de l'ordre de 100 kilowatts heure 100
kilowatts heure d'énergie mécanique
c'est scarlett rue main bien entraînées
et capables de fournir maximum maximorum
avec ces gens fonctionnent ali si
maintenant je le rends une paire de bras
donc je remplace les excavateurs
ce risque oui immobiliers par des pelles
des pioches et des pelles des pioches et
bien une personne qui m'a dit l'appel et
l'interruption du gordel ont décaissé si
l'équipe de der est en montée d'un mètre
par al capone et bien lui il va me font
dire c'est que 0 5 kilowatt heure et
s'il paie ça un jour sur deux pointures
fois il va faire dit qu'il aurait peur
par kilowattheure ridicule ridicule
c'est l'énergie pesait dans des sens
vous faites pour les arrivées sens et
bien l'énergie de combustion de votre
lit des sens c'est un peu près 10
kilowatts heure et une fois vous allez
faire passer ce avant la date heure vous
allez on ressortir de la carte
kilowattheures d'énergie mécanique
dit autrement dans un petit litre
d'essence
un petit lit descente vous avez la même
quantité de transformation du monde que
dans dix jours le travail de force que
quelqu'un qui utilise ses jambes et dans
100 jours de travail de force lequel
inclut liste et moi dans un litre
d'essence dans le fond de transformer
kong avec un gilet sens autant que ti
personnes travailleront jour avec leurs
jambes 100 personnes
des prix si vous utilisez les sens ou
dépassée vous maîtrisez l'environnement
à quelques dizaines de centimes du
kilowattheure par contre si vous prenez
un ouvrier veille au smic pour arrêt en
france on a manqué volontairement et
bien vous allez payer kilowattheures
d'énergie mécanique de son long s'il
s'agit de ses jambes 2000 euros s'il
s'agit de ses rangs je redis autrement
en france
quand vous modifier l'environnement que
vous modifiez physiquement
l'environnement avec des paires de bras
deux jambes ça vous 500 à 5 fois plus
cher que si vous mettez de l'essence
dans sa bulle de verre 500 à 5000 fois
j'ai dit autrement grâce à l'énergie
abondante et à lennart d'exosquelette
que nous avons créé une tour de doux
sous forme de bulldozer de machines à
café
l'ascenseur de pont de charge de
convoyeurs etc
il ya bien la capacité de modifier
l'environnement pour quelques centaines
de fois plus quelque chose est deux fois
plus élevé que ce que nous ferions avec
jusqu'au bout
si on est politiquement très incorrect
et on utilise des esclaves est
normalement tout à fait interdite qu'est
ce que vous faites avec indesca
l'acheter c'est un peu d'argent vous
êtes nourrir parce que sinon bieber
pourrait l'empêcher pour 3
et bien si vous faites le compte même ça
ça vous avait des kilowattheures
d'énergie mécanique pour 10 à 100 fois
plus cher que la magie du dividende
naissance mon sentiment comme seul à
penser ça c'est que l' esclavage n'a pas
disparu ou parce que l'offre foncière du
bronze
pourquoi que le code génétique échangés
en sidération c'est juste devenu
totalement inintéressant sur un comique
c'est la raison pour laquelle esclavage
a disparu ceux ci allemagne cela je ne
sais pas si ça tiendra dans un monde qui
gère ou quatre ans je ne gère pas sa
décrue une argile je vous rappelle que
l'ancien rona et l'ancien les citoyens
libres représentait un dixième au moins
cinq centièmes des esclaves qui
trouvaient autour de la cité pour faire
en sorte que les citoyens libres
maintenant de vivre la démocratie
manquements donc le l'ordre de grandeur
que je vous expose la est à mon avis le
truc qui a fait l'essentiel du monde qui
nous entoure et partant les regrets quel
pouvoir d'achat
voorhees les érables alors voilà
maintenant comment a évolué et l'esquivé
en ville au water l'approvisionnement
énergétique par personne sur terre de
biens cédés
il s'agit d'un arrangement par personne
s'est exprimée en kilowattheures par an
alors ce que vous voyez c'est que ya un
siècle et demi mais les lointains sans
cesse et les autres qu'on savait à peu
près 1500 km heure d'énergie par an
c'est d'essentiel choses cruelles
charbon de bois ça servait de rester
sans
par ailleurs la chaleur un peu au début
de la machine à vapeur quatre ans les
cadeaux et un peu au début de la
métallurgie et puis avec le temps le
charbon commente puis le pétrole vient
se rajouter son charme on ne remplace
pas du tout puis le gaz vient se
rajouter sur les deux précédents puis et
serra et vous voyez que toutes les
formes d'énergie que nous avons utilisée
se sont empilées les unes sur les autres
alors je vais revenir après au pétrole
parce qu'il s'est quand même déjà passé
des trucs sur le pétrole globalement ces
formes d'énergie sans fil d une surface
vous voyez que l'énergie vous commencez
à voir quelque chose que je peux vous
dire tout à l'heure c'est à dire qu'il
ya quand même des variations fortes sur
l'énergie pendant son fort sur
l'économie mondiale
vous voyez quelque chose de très
significatif c'est que jusqu'au choc
pétrolier vous avez une énergie
disponible par personne qui augmentent
fortement +2 quelque chose qu'on s'en
tape
après les champs pétroliers de risque
d'augmentation devient beaucoup plus
faible et j'y reviens vers un peu plus
tard ce qui s'est passé au moment des
chocs pétroliers qui a commencé à des
planchers tous les troubles économiques
que nous connaissons aujourd'hui c'est
pas à variation sur le prix c'est assez
derrière ces appareils seront connus les
chocs pétroliers ses débuts d'une
énergie par personne du corps va être
contrainte d'augmenter
alors vous voyez que ça a recommencé à
augmenter son lit
année en fait tout mon corps est tout à
leur environnement énergétique d'un
certain nombre de pays européens on ne
rentre pas du tout comme ça que ça fasse
sens pas du tout commencé à remonter sur
le ring à 15 années ces dix dernières
années elles ont une origine majeur
c'est l'augmentation très forte du
charbon jument fort à tout à l'heure
il ya un pays qui est à l'origine de
cette augmentation qui appelle à chypre
donc là vous avez un effet de moyenne
si vous enlevez le jargon chinois
l'augmentation de la quantité d'énergie
consommée par personne sur les dix
dernières années vous l'avez membres
alors nous profitons tous un peu de
charme chinois à chaque fois que nous
achetons un truc pays china blue
vachement à tous les médicaments mais
c'est bien ce que vous voyez également
c'est que la quantité de sarrebourg /
place des parents mondiale l'âge avait
décru depuis qu'on a commencé à utiliser
du charbon des partants la quantité
totale de charbon utilisé dans le monde
à jamais des clubs alors aujourd'hui
nous sommes arrivés à ces états très
particulier où nous avons tous à travers
la consommation d'énergie dit rien
l'équivalent de 200 esclaves à notre
disposition 24 h sur 24
dit autrement si nous n'avions pas les
machines publicité tout à l'heure un
couple les autres et l'énergie
il faudrait que la terre soit dotée
d'une exoplanète où il y aurait cette
fois deux cent mille 400 milliards
d'individus rhin pénalité de la journée
et c'est ça qui nous assurerait votre
depuis que nous avons aujourd'hui sur la
planète
et si je prends un français c'est pas 2
ans de 5 6 ans donc si la france n'avait
pas des machines alimenté à l'énergie
fossile excessive et bien il faudrait
que nous ayons 3 milliards d'individus
en première approximation à notre
disposition en train de pédaler en
permanence et c'est ça qui lui
permettrait de vivre aujourd'hui
question à laquelle s'attaque rapide
alors évidemment cette fréquence à
plusieurs c'est ça qui a fait
l'augmentation de la productivité du
travail et c'est ça qui a fait la
structure des mini break
enfin en matière d'électricité d'abord
je vous rappelle une chose cette
électricité est une énergie une finale
donc l'électricité est aussi propre ou
sale la manière de la vole bien il est
sympathique véhiculées dans les médias
que l'électricité sera une énergie
propre et pendant
rodez parce que je le répète l'énergie
est aussi son coup salle que la manière
de la conduire la manière de les
reproduire aujourd'hui dans le monde
elle est presque parler que ça il en
avait amené champs pétroliers c'est à
dire que les combustibles fossiles
représentent les deux tiers est en tête
on va trouver changement l'essentiel de
l'augmentation des capacités électriques
dans le monde sur les dernières
décennies c'est le charme
l'essentiel des capacités en
construction aujourd'hui dans le monde
c'est le charbon
ce que vainqueur n'a pas pris la tête
dans le débat tout à l'heure pour se
passer du nucléaire c'est entre autres
pour fuir des capacités au charme à la
presse française dans un de moins que
des éoliennes est ce que c'est un moment
sympa mais ça fait aller dans ce parti a
validé dans l'électricité est justement
fait dire là dessus que la majorité star
d'art dans le monde si elle fait une
tonne et qu'elle est alimentée avec le
électricité est produite avec cela elle
sépare de co2 capturé
donc j'ai une famille les connecte au
réseau du pétrole le charbon ne s'est
pas une folie des pensions et climat
cette énergie argumente et ça si c'est
quelque chose d'absolument centrale
comprendra politique culture à sur la
durée
totalement déformé la structure des
métiers alors maintenant j'ai augmenté
la france v6 jeu pour l'espagne s'est
passé exactement à jaws part exactement
j'ai le temps et si je regarde si en
train de se passer aujourd'hui dans un
certain nombre de pays de l'europe qui
connaissent ou ont connu un
approvisionnement énergétique fortement
points sans ces derniers temps il aurait
tardé à convaincre
donc voilà la structure des métiers en
france sur le dos d'un demi siècle
donc je prends un français et les deux
siècles 203 d'agriculteurs ou ivan
dernier ça que vous voulez il a pas
d'utilité agricole de l'époque est telle
que c'est un dollar ces femmes là est
capable de se trouver lui +0 5 actif qui
fait au jour il ya deux siècles
le français qui vont au boulot se lève
le matin dès 500m pour les branches en
distance moyenne parcourue par personne
et par jour il ya du sexe étaient en
bleu km à kiel aller au turbin ça donc
je belle josée longchamps
je vais pousser la date des gens et en
faisant sa mémoire et je nourris 05
personnes qui votent
et puis avec le temps on se met à avoir
une industrie qui se développe grâce à
l'énergie
cette industrie la plus des premières
foulées va faire c'est des engins
agricoles performantes du charles pour
la forme et c'est à la fin du xixème
siècle boyaval les premières machines à
sous à peu tiré par les dizaines de
chevaux donc n'abuse fils d énergie de
l'agriculture la productivité agricole
pendant déjà de manière significative
comme les surfaces cultivées elles sont
comme shipyards sauter là eh bien il ya
plein de gens qui se mettent à pouvoir
faire autre chose que de faire pousser
les patates
nous sommes vraiment qu'il n'y a pas
d'énergie et plein de ressources et des
parts des poissons des arbres des guides
à elle est une des rares qu'on va faire
j'élève des retraites par exemple des
plus de dix objets des régulières pour
exploiter tout à fait pour des layènes
tout ce que la nature mire de
dispositions en quantité croissante avec
de l'énergie en passant ça s'appelle
nash de l'envoyer se développer là et
une fois dans la fabrique et il faut
rend il faut comptabiliser il faut
financer cet art ça s'appelle les
services et/ou aguilar
et puis comme une partie des gens vivent
bien merci
ces gens là ils ont besoin de services
personnels des gardes l'enfant des
bottes etc
c'est une partie significative un des
services et matériels dont la musique
est serré et puis arrive le champ
pétrolier et le choc pétrolier par que
la fin de la hausse de la quantité
d'énergie disponible par personne
du coup à ce moment là le flux global
l'art est d'augmenter
poussée par l'énergie par contre il
continue à augmenter poussé par les
gains de productivité liée à une
meilleure aux astuces la technique
donc on se retrouve avec juste les gains
liés à des pics mais plus les gains liés
à l'énergie et à ce moment le flux
global ne va plus assez vite pour les
gens les gardent comme unité militaire
grâce à la technique et le secteur
commence en convention à se dégonfler
mais c'est aussi à cette époque on voit
apparaître une nouvelle catégorie de
travailleurs qui n'existait pas avant
avec toi au moment du premier choc
pétrolier vous voyez apparaître le
chômage dit structurel c'est à dire que
vous avez tel productivité chez les gens
travaillent à cause de l'énergie que
vous avez en permanence une trace son
chemin à faire en permanence sur faction
cantal
alors il ya des sociétés dans lesquelles
on a planté c'est génial dans les
endroits où vous attendent à côté de
l'ascenseur parce qu'au japon mais
voyard il est partout encore une fois
partie des gens qui sont improductifs au
sens où on l'entendait avant c'est à
dire qu'il faut pas besoin de travailler
la matière n'ont pas grande gérer des
objets travail et il sera un peu les
choses se passent d'une soupe sous une
bande jours c'est aussi grâce à ça du
reste c'est aussi à gauche tout ça j'ai
pas compte des pailles et pouvoir et
enfler la dette
en tête il ya des questions alors là ça
c'est une vision dynamique pour la
france maintenant je vais vous montrer
comme pour les autres pays dans glee
s'est passé la même chose au club dont
il se passe des choses
vous avez ici un graphique qui vous
donne pour chaque point de leurs grandes
abbayes normandes et pour chaque pays
dans le monde
en abscisse vous n'avez la quantité
d'énergie utilisée par personne et par
an et on dort données vous avez la
fraction des gens qui travaillent dans
l'agriculture est bien ce que vous voyez
de manière absolument spectaculaire à
part quelques points singuliers
c'est que plus la d'énergie disponible
par personne et moi y attendait donc
l'exode rural et une contrepartie
inexorable inexorable de la route de la
quantité d'énergie disponible dans un
pays voilà autre chose pendant que je
vais revenir à la seconde
sowell aussi sur ce graphique c'est que
contrairement à lui les grandes étendues
la région va faire bien voir de publier
le société créée par deux mandats series
et n'est pas une société dématérialisé
c'est une société qui est très fortement
énergivores et qui a confié toutes les
tâches prévues qu'il allait agir
mangeant m'énerve c'est à ce moment que
les gens sont ils disponibles pour faire
des études est allé dans un mot
les informations dans les sociétés qui
ne consomment pas beaucoup d'énergie il
ya pas d art et la paix les appels à
pedro c'est la marque des sociétés qui
consomment beaucoup d'énergie et on le
voit typiquement sur ce graphique ou là
vous avez pour tous les pays dans le
monde que j'avais les statistiques
infraction d'emploi que vous avez dans
les services et en ordonnée les
émissions de co2 par personne et par an
c'est à dire la consommation d'énergies
fossiles en personne pas et bien on peut
l'on prend interrogé sur la qualité de
la corrélation à la hausse par contre un
truc absolument certain ses tapas
correctionnel ne voyait pas sur ce
graphique plus avant que dans les
services et plus les élections d'un
personnes sur mars
c'est la seule chose que vous n'avez pas
cela donc l'idée sympathique qui est
insuffisant soit dans un long cours avec
le big ben est loin des cas quand ils en
sortent pour dématérialiser l'économie
s'est malheureusement totalement faux ça
correspond au contraire à une économie
fortement matérialisme maintenant je
vous dis que notre manière mon sentiment
c'est qu'une économie qui ce qui
l'utilisera moins d'énergie est une
économie dans laquelle on transpire à
puce en janvier courant a pas répondu
qui est que on affichera en vie sera
rien je le vois pas je crois d une
société dans laquelle tous bien rendu
les choses mais en tout cas je pense à
ces chauves-souris alors je vous le
disais tout à l'heure
l'énergie c'est la transformation
l'énergie permet donc pour transformer
toutes les matières qui sont disponibles
sur terre on dit si vous avez la
consommation d'énergie
la justice va tellement parlé ça par
coeur c'est juste pour goodyear grâce à
l'énergie on transforme tous absolument
tous les métros les matériels carrière
et c'est ce qui pousse
bref on transporte absolument tout ce
qui vous permet d'avoir un guerrier
kolsek que vous avez autant de gérer
tout à l'heure dans cette salle
y'a rien d'autre que des ressources
naturelles transformé par denner la
règle que ça complètement les photos
mais que cet ordinateur ce public les
grandes
tout ça c'est des ressources naturelles
transformer dans les galeries cet
immeuble alors on va jouer ça et bien on
va comprendre pourquoi il est là qu
économiques sont devenues à peu de
choses près à ces villages entre un
drapeau vous avez ici la représentation
classique du système économique que en
général à l'habitude de manipuler
quand monsieur hollande invité de
capital qui va regarder mais je fais à
parier que l'une a sorti des trucs qui
marque les collants est donc vous avez
un pays des productions qui découle de
facteurs de conduction le capital
les investissements entre 10 et le
travail ou le nombre de gens le père de
roy qui sont disponibles sur le marché
si le pib a gagné un peu et bien c'est
qu'il n'y a pas d'investissement bni
thomas
cette ambition nous fait vraiment
connaître et elle évite aux salariés
c'est un bien pour gagner faut gagner
manga deux mois et priver par partie on
a essayé cette recette à petite dose ou
avoir congo ça dépend des pays
et ça ne va pas nécessairement en lien
avec une hausse du pib
exemple la grande bretagne à grande
bretagne vous avez énormément d'argent
qui circule
vous avez des travailleurs pauvres la
guerre qu'ils ont livrée dès l'enfance
de chômage baisser de la fédération et
la bretagne peut prendre comme tous les
bâtiments construits sur son pib
donc c'est que ça suffira c'est pour ça
que marche ne suffit pas d'avoir des
gens qui travaillent trop cher et la
langue kurde est la raison pour laquelle
ça suffira simplement que cette
représentation que total - m il manque
juste un petit détail
où sont les choses dit autrement si vous
regardez physiquement laurent
s'organisent notre système productif
c'est ce que je disais tout à l'heure
notre système productif c'est rien
d'autre que des ressources naturelles
gratuite transformé par pratiques des
pays
c'est ça la production des ombres le
tableau derrière il est gratuit les
hydrocarbures
gratuit personne dans cette salle que ce
soit votre forme d'être en ligue 1
l'air que vous respirez et gratuit le
soleil la nature de l'information prend
le sol et le système climatique et
l'océan et le code génétique des
poissons tout ça devrait donner ma boss
tu n'as pas le payer un centime à existe
par contre nous on serait de la barre
qui aura pêcher les poissons avec un
bateau ou faire faire dans le sens et
même si je voulais ou de l'huile
intersidéral regarde en vente bien
garnie de big ben et sa grosse bourde
d'un club de vannes arrière un système
du type d'organisme la voici notre
système productif c'est des ressources
transformé par des pratiques le capital
c'est le couple interdit cette saison
c'est pareil mais c'est un immeuble
c'est des ressources et du travail
passer d'ordinateur c'est des ressources
et du travail passé un stock de
progresser les ressources du travail le
capital c'est bien d'autres que des
ressources et du travail passé donc
voilà comment s'organise le système est
dans le travail c'est à dire la capacité
à transformer en source
comme je vous l ai dit tout à l'heure
mon bus tout rond point l'énergie qui
arrange les machines deux autres une
fois vous avez ça vous comprenez comment
système s'organise de manière très
logique
quand vous avez un capital d'un travail
que vous avez un goulet d'étranglement
sur l'énergie disponible nous aurons
simplement sur le pib ont senti maxi
vous avec un travail même si vous avez
vainqueur final et si vous avez un
goulet d'étranglement sur les ressources
vous aurez aussi à goulet d'étranglement
sur le pib en sortir alors le deuxième
point qu'on va traiter aujourd'hui de
manière détaillée par contre grillé on
va y revenir de manière non seulement
détaillé et quand il alors se tire avec
cela va passer à fait aux rires en
dessert si effectivement on a un rapport
de un à deux sens entre eux le pib par
an sur notre travail et l'énergie qui
arrange des machines on doit s'attendre
à ce que le pib paris au regard comme
l'énergie que mangent les machines et
c'est bien car vous avez ce graphique
envers la variation de la quantité
d'énergie consommée dans le monde et en
bleu la variation du bébé manga vous
voyez ce qu'on s'attend à trouver
c'est-à-dire de pib paris très
exactement très exactement comme
l'énergie consommée par exemple d'enfant
représentation avec forza pas si vous
avez ici un graphique sur lequel je suis
désolé j'ai pas encore le pib 2012 j'ai
l'énergie 2012 n'a pas encore payé dès
dernier point vous avez série point qui
m'a 1965 à 2011
là et pour chaque point j'ai dit en
abscisse deux pays les médias delà des
dollars constants par la consommation
d'énergie de l'année et en ordonnée et
pib de l'année en delacourt soir et bien
ce que vous voyez c'est que c'est pour
un s'organise de manière extrêmement
remarquable le lot de droite donc le
modèle un prix d'ami de mise et le voit
si vous avez besoin d'avoir quantité
d'énergie et sur le long terme
vous n'êtes pas vraiment d'avoir le pays
vous voyez même un point de regroupement
en 2009 la sas à ramsar ordinateur donc
le alors c'est normal dans le coin
l'énergie c'est la transformation
physique
l'économie c'est la transformation
économique dit autrement la valeur
ajoutée dont la somme des pib 5 ans et
ce pont à une transformation la valeur
ajoutée s'est transformé en poste qui
remplace qui sort de l'entreprise entre
les deux les quelque chose alors les
quelque chose que tu modifications de
forme de lieux nos couleurs de la vente
voire vous avez modifié et en sortie
s'est modifié vous avez donc de
l'amarrage des et de l'énergie est
interne à ce qu'on vous dit ce graphique
c'est que profond l'efficacité
énergétique sur les 50 dernières années
a assez variés et danser les gars joly
c'est à dire la transformation physique
qui pilote lavallois
bd on va maintenant au théoriser un
petit peu tout ça avec près de 300
compliqué qu'un problème mécanique alors
avec détroit puisqu'elle dit elle
commence par dire que le pib mondial des
galas du rêve sur toi j'espère que ça va
je dirigeais multiplient à droite par
l'énergie alors soit c'est ce facteur
j'ai pas choisi au hasard aurait pu
multiplier diviser la loi par le bond
des pôles tonnerre dans l'océan
atlantique
vous faites baisser et paul demers là le
pays dès son énergie encore une fois
c'est combien de rebelles heures a
ajouté cheikh pour combien de
rectification du monde j'ai fait en bas
âge modifié monde hauteur as à tarbes le
kilowattheure en eau
j'ai appelé à des grèves il ya toujours
ya jamais lassant il ya belle terre bio
sur le terminal et je vais rajouter la
population parce que pays-bas personnes
comme vous le savez c'est la fiche de
paye cher qu'aux déclarations campagne
et donc c'est quelque chose qui est
d'importance dans les débats publics
donc ce que j'ai à dire c'est que le pib
par personne
les revenus par personne sont
strictement et oui à l'égard personnes
fois l'efficacité d'arudy de l'économie
kenyane et 7 à l'heure je vais regarder
comme un pari longtemps alors au premier
rang
vérifiez sur les scènes que j'ai raison
la variation dans le temps du pib n'a
personne d'autre en iran c'est la
passion d'antan de l'énergie par
personne plus la variation vantant de
l'efficacité énergétique de l'école
alors si vous regardez énergie par
personne c'est ce que je vous ai monté
tout à l'heure justement 74 20 juin pour
arrêter ça augmentait de 8 2% par an
après 0 4 mois et mondial
l'efficacité énergétique de l'écologie
oro augmente d'arbres qui ploient un
patron
elle augmente d'un petit point par an
sur l'e40 d'arrêt des lessives en garde
ils ont gravi qu'en fait pour constater
qu'il ya un peu moins de berio ne manque
pas de nous entre 60 et 70 et sur la
dernière décennie pour dire l'efficacité
énergétique de l'économie
c'est un truc qui nous est donné c'est
un cul ça va tout en lançant sa est ce
que nous disons que la théorie c'est que
le pays débat personne en fuite doit
donc monté de plus de 30% par an à 80,05
hayward est d'avoir plus de 1% par an
après 1980 alors on va regarder ce que
disent les chiffres ici vous avez la
variation du pib par personne en moyenne
mondiale depuis 1960
et vous voyez que effectivement pendant
les trente glorieuses en moyenne par des
saisies
rennes par des saisies on est bien avant
les 3 % les choses par an et que ap les
champs pétroliers en moyenne sur la
période
on est bien on a vu des choses qu'on
s'empare d'un bon sentiment c'est que
ceux ci allaient toujours avec cela je
ne vois pas de raison majeure pour
laquelle à partir de maintenant il
faudrait faire les budgets d'état
français et les plans pour l'avenir avec
aux chaussures non je ne crois pas
personnellement et je vois peu quand
moins une raison majeure qu'il ya
peut-être quelques chefs d'entreprise
dans cette salle
peut-être quelques cas choisi pour
intention à leur budget vous savez comme
moi c'est plus facile de dépenser de
l'argent dormant à gagner un peu plus
que ce à quoi on s'attendait que de
calais ses recettes sur un arbre
n'arrivera pas et d'essayer derrière lui
des vernis donc la plage vous mettre à
partir de maintenant on fasse des
budgets publics avec une croissance
nulle voire vers une croissance négative
de leur internement
avec une déjà question qui est plus en
danger mais ici en apprend plus ou moins
anticipée coup et on s'est organisé avec
ce qui va nous arriver même si il ya des
côtés france à paris rapporte on est
quand même mieux si on sait à peu près à
quelle sauce on dérangeait que si mon
rêve est que derrière
à l'arrivée c'est un avis c'est comme ça
qu'il soit interdit donc ce que je vous
ai raconté depuis
au début de cette intervention c'est que
vous avez les ressources et les
hydrocarbures
58 les hydrocarbures dans la capacité de
france environ 10 par les codeurs réagi
ça vous a donné la tonalité de son tour
saint gilles a donné la productivité du
travail et donc ça nous a donné des
études longues
les retraites la mondialisation les
d'abord à l'augmentation de la surface
habitable par personne à mobilité pour
tous et apparaitra tout ça c'est les
conséquences de l'état gère tout ça
c'est quand les gens alors dans le nom
de aïn draham dans le monde dans lequel
on vit ça pose de questions la première
c'est qu'est ce qu'on peut dire sur la
crise devant adam et quand je dis qu'est
ce qu'on peut dire c'est qu'est ce qu'on
peut dire regarde un peu les chiffres et
qu'on va rendre visite et les critères
techniques
quand juste convivial et qu'est ce qu'on
peut dire sur le fait de mettre dans
l'atmosphère des gaz via tordent les
approches et reste ça c'est pareil
est-ce que là dans l'un et où l'autre
y'a pas des tracteurs les 80 qui vont
faire en sorte que l'expansion
perpétuelle va être un peu difficile à
jouer on va commencer par le premier
problème est le palais pour avoir lancé
à rappeler encore une fois très dur at
talah et la petite reine la tête il
giornale ça elle dit que si je tape
parce que les barques de développement
imaginez que chez vous il ya un stock de
bouteilles bouteille à voir
et puis ce stock est donnée de 20 pouces
vous êtes d'accord avec moi que vous ne
pourrez pas voir chaque jour un nombre
croissant bouteille jusqu'à la pile
étant d'accord si vous avez un solde et
les marques donné deux fois pour toutes
vous pouvez par chaque jour tu avais
encore plus fort
et en europe vous ne pourrez même pas
boire chaque jour à repentigny neige de
la nuit des temps même si ces maps il si
vous avez un score de départ loading
fort que tout
vous ne pouvez pas taper de temps chaque
jour albi moteur pour la benetton en
fait l'alerté aurait des maths vous
permet de démontrer
quand vous avez un stock de départ
d'ozil fois pour toutes vous ne pouvez
pas échapper à croire plusieurs vous
allez partir de zéro terminé à 0 entre
les deux lorrains du caire son bord à
moins qu'on reproche et employés de
dornach expendables est donc vous aurez
quelque chose qui va s'avérer pour
l'exclu le prix des denrées essentielles
un produit se vend des faits ça sera
pareil nous oeuvrons le pétrole et gaz
mais aussi pour tous les migraines
chroniques mais aussi pour le charbon
dès que vous avez quelque chose encore
une fois que disponible en quantité
donnée sans doute ou lenovo carrière peu
importe vous aurez un pic à l'esam les
seules questions
la seule question celle des animaux en
plus tard et est-ce que c'est grave
docteur
riche parce que ça concerne après un
spectacle
terrell je crois jamais les intérêts
s'ils s'imposent à nous défendre c'est
plus emmerdant to this un concert des
silex
s'il ya des en fonction du sujet
concerné c'est grave c'est ma façon
d'occuper faut pas s'en occuper et 36%
prendre non pas laisser croire mais
c'est un objet mathématique certains ça
c'est absolument essentiel avant alors
prévoir les futures c'est facile quand
son passé
voilà un exemple au bik s'agir grande
découverte il ya une quantité donnée que
des rôles avec de l'eau sur terre à
scander aimons vous avez nécessairement
un flic pour des mères des mères on se
dit qu il est passé à l'école de ma
naissance
voyez ici les découvertes de pétrole et
gaz du groupe érable qui sont radiées
par deux mines et c'est en milliards de
l'iphone donc ça veut dire par exemple
que dans la première moitié de la
décennie 60 entre 60 et 65 pour a
découvert 400 milliards de baril
équivalent pétrole et de gaz la danse
sans école et un peu plus de 100
milliards que vous avez en eau la plus
grand champ télé couvert sur la période
ça c'est plus grand champ des foyers de
monde en arabie saoudite
ça et ça c'est le droitier des plus
grands champs gaziers du monde donc on
avec la découverte risque fortement à
ces déchets sont à découvert au large du
brésil y'a pas le temps l'ardoisé taille
là alors il assure que pour les
actionnaires des fours-à-chaux laser ça
ne changera pas la donne mondiale
donc ça ne va pas je reste d'aller voir
sur le graphique suivant que ça ne
change pas alors en ce qui concerne
l'extraction du sol voilà vous chante
les étapes intermédiaires voilà ans
ressemble aura vraisemblablement bronze
aurait vraisemblablement la
disponibilité mondiale en liquide alors
ça ça a créé des primaires et du final
c'est pas très graphique
cette partie à cette épaule droite ils
sortent des albums ça c'est le
d'étranges bruits qui sort des gisements
en offshore profond
ça s'est déjà fait les bric c'est du
pétrole de synthèse tissu des pétroles
et strasbourg que vous avez dans la
ceinture genre évacuer la et les sables
bitumineux que vous avez au canada c'est
déjà du pétrole de synthèse 120 équipes
de r ça c'est ce qu'on appelle les
liquides de gaz ces molécules c2a c5 que
vous trouvez gorillaz qui sont gazeuse à
température et pression de gisements
équivoque de guerre liquide à
température ordinaire pression a reconnu
bert et là vous avez le fait grand bruit
dans une raffinerie en volume qu'en sera
peu plus encore de raffiner l'écran les
aventures durant etc
exxon là en ce qui concerne le mode
conventionnel
il est raisonnable pour les quatre
dispose que le pic mondial est passé ya
quelques années le médecin ou des
risques
or ce qui concerne le bruit tout
confondu avec un choix extra lourd s'est
pas encore tout de suite qu'on va garder
sur un plateau qui va durer encore
jusqu'en 2020 avant au déclin et si vous
rajoutez à ça notre atlantique de gaz
avec une production mondiale de gaz mais
dans trois cent six minutes actives et
bien vous allez des liquides qui pour le
moment sont encore en croissance
pour information des agrocarburants
la production mondiale dakar d'or en
2012 j'ai des gars est bon at home inns
les tout petits est présente avec cinq
sens du progrès
donc vous voyez ici c'est que si le pic
c'est eva hier ça sera demain et si
c'est pas demain c'est vraiment une
autre banque mondiale comme maxime
mondiale et à cause de l'effet
d'éviction lié au fait que les pays
producteurs réserves croissantes de leur
production à leur propre secteur parce
que les iraniens avec atari les russes
dont les cochons des deux listes du coup
il ya une fraction croissante du défunt
qui produisent lit car pour eux et la
quantité que peuvent être sur le marché
mondial pour les gens comme des français
qui n'importe où pas ans emprunte à cet
effet d'alors depuis 2005
depuis 2005 et de comment on a passé le
pic de brut conventionnel
et bien c'est elle et vous verrez la
réalité sur le droit pour les fêtes et
50 alors souvent les ans quotas question
quand ils voient ça ou bien ce que ça a
coûté est en fait c'est triplement à la
question c'est triplement par la
question
d'abord parce que vous participerez m'en
occupe vous avez ici en rouge ce qui a
été le prix du pétrole en 1985 et toutes
les courts de couleur orange et al c'est
les projections prix qui ont été faites
année après année par l'agencé
internationale
l'énergie dont 20 par rapport vous savez
le world est l'un des accidents les
entreprises qui sont ici et là pour un
parti s'amuser à faire des écarts
importants entre la réalité et la coupe
en bois il reste m'est donc ces points
d'austin ont strictement du mail la
deuxième chose c'était au joug de la
dictature a pris il ya plus d'élasticité
hyrule vous avez ici un graphique qui a
été fait par un scientifique mec qui a
soit dit en passant était conseiller
scientifique du gouvernement blair grave
pour l'instant et il a dix mois après
mois
sur ce graphique entre 98 et 2005 le
prix du pétrole et le volume de la
production mondiale est ici la même
chose entre 2005 et 2010
bon ce que vous voyez c'est en 98 et de
parfums 2004 un relais correspond à un
environnement pour le moment il a cité
un pylône ce que vous voyez après donc
la production est à brax entreprises
estime donc je vous donne une production
d'enr sud rien est d'accord les
partenaires par contre il ya autre chose
vous ne savez pas non plus ce que semble
donc tout budget les épaules à venir en
disant je prends pas pour le prix du
pétrole
jean cézard
ça peut être plus bas et donc on va
rentrer dans une r21 de raccorder bien
ça pour les étudiants où le business
plan va devenir un exercice pour les
listes on va faire court de distribution
des résultats possibles et non pas un
business plan avec un chiffre virgule
deux chiffres derrière lui laisser ça
comme en général
en tout cas ses ventes et comprendra
donc c'est pas à nous de répondre autre
graphique qui montre qu'on ne sait pas
le cri de sujets vous avez ici une un
gage de pointe qui va de 1960 à 2011 et
pour chaque point j'ai mis le pib
mondial ont ordonné et le prix de
barrières en abscisse si le pib mondial
devrait deux portés et non de prix du
baril du pétrole baissent l'éloge de
loin de l'être a organisé comme ça hors
prix des progrès c'est pénible gamme
comme on dit quand le pays du détroit
commander des nuages de points de la tva
pour exposer comme ça y'a pas bien vous
avez le prix du pétrole qui met cette
saison
les vols du monde est effectivement de
lui mettre une punaise parce que tout ça
c'est une époque où la quantité globale
de pétrole continuent d'augmenter et
c'est ça qui compte pour faire augmenter
le pib pourrait après le prix il n'a
arbitré les frontières de rentes entre
les importateurs et les exportateurs
c'est tout ce qu'ils veulent la remise
du tenseur de rente au sein d'un pays
entre les producteurs et les
consommateurs et entre pays entre les
exportateurs et les importateurs
c'est tout ce qui fait alors rouge et
noir un bloc bas à un peu plus loin que
la revente ils les arbitres qu'un patch
encore des erreurs mais ça de chevet ce
que les uns vers les autres mégane et
après le qatar et que par exemple
donc ça invitons les trains sur deux ans
au prix du pétrole
sa larme à l'oeil des médias alors les
concerts rencontrent ils sont gérants
ici vous avez la facture énergétique de
l'union donc là on va commencer à parler
d'europe ont mis en dollars constants je
suis désolé j'avais fait quelques temps
en train je n'ai pas mis sur le même
stade
nous observons le niveau de virus donc
ce que vous avez ici c'est la quantité
totale d'argent que l'europe des bourses
pour aborder du pétrole du gaz et les
charges
est ce que vous voyez c'est qu'en 2011
ça faisait un peu près 600 milliards de
dollars par an de moins de 500 milliards
d'euros et en 2001 en 2012 ses intérêts
par les silent s'y plier en gros par six
depuis 2008 et ceci avec cette
augmentation de la facture et avec
l'augmentation du prix du pétrole
l'automobiliste français aujourd'hui et
une taxe carbone à 200 euros la tonne
russes les irlandais ont lu celui bien
voilà où on en paye les nationales à 200
euros la tonne c'est ça que représente
l'augmentation du prix du baril on a su
bien dans les villes et 2010
le seul à payer un immeuble de faire des
jo l'un des gens qui dansent prochaine
autre petit calcul amusant d'en tirer de
ces fonds servant vous avez ici
un avis qui vous donne sur les 20
dernières années
finalement en bas la quantité totale
d'argent qu'on a déboursé pour acheter
du pétrole d'igarka s'accumulent et en
gros l'augmentation globale de la
demande étant alors raisonnement idiot
si vous avez quelque chose à quelqu'un
d'autre et que vous n'avez pas l'argent
si vous faites donc tu vous voyez ici
alors évidemment mon raisonnement ne
consiste pas à dire tout de suite que
cet argent a servi qu'à ça laisse que
vous voyez c'est l'augmentation de la
dette correspond peu à la candide et
l'argent qu'il a fallu sortir
les bidasses raconte encore une fois si
vous avez un déficit commercial
ça se retrouve donc à préciser les
attentes étaient trop de gaz de deux
éléments qui étaient présentés dans le
débat national de l'hiver c'est le plus
important
il ya deux trucs qui n'étaient pas dans
le débat ses dessins alors vous allez
bien la france est un pays d'à
d'intervenants pas vraiment avoir des
enfants qu'ils sont sérieux voilà les
tâches récemment dans certaines
différences et maintenant allons voir
chez les gens en ce moment vie privée
dans le discours européen en expliquant
qu'ils ont fait leurs devoirs dont deux
à dix espagnols évidemment pour tous les
gens qui se font au soleil les grecs
sopi la ronde
safa si vous avez envers l'environnement
et donc portugais italiens grecs
espagnols et vous voyez exactement la
structure dit autrement il ya un an est
vital en ce qui concerne l'europe qui
est arrêté d'importer des hydrocarbures
au public comme ses parts avec les gaz
de schiste à l'étranger doute finir avec
ça veut dire que des cars données et
déjà plus d'options fond nous c'est une
impérieuse nécessité
alors je le disais tout à l'heure le
prix art qui sont les transferts de
rentrer par tous évolué mari de bb ou
bien vous avez six en rouge un truc qui
vous ramène ce que je vais déjà montré
la variation de la quantité totale de
pétrole pour sauver sur terre quand il
est aux tables des transmissions ce
public nom de marque
la variation de la quantité de l'aï
conservé son sable et en bleu où vous
avez la variation du pays les bahamas
alors quelques conclusions majeures
avant les chocs pétroliers
l'économie est moins dépendant du
pétrole est aujourd'hui moins
aujourd'hui vous avez à bayonne décroche
pas disponible vous détruisez beaucoup
plus de pib comme dans détruisiez avant
les chocs pétroliers au refuge
le deuxième saut ce que vous voyez ces
lieux sur les deux épisodes récents de
deux récentes le pétrole pressel le pays
et gère bien mais après tout les pays
européens comptent un peu je ne pourrai
donc c'est pas bon se défendre parce que
c'est la crise c'est d'abord la réforme
et ensuite si on joue les rues
l'explication est hâtive - pétrole -
confort il n'y a pas qu'une entreprise
dans ce pays qui est et l'ampli spatiale
qui lui permet d'éviter l'engorgement ou
aux voitures et aux noms étranges un
confort encore un bel et bien sûr encore
une fois c'est le pétrole précède la
variation ce bébé est aujourd'hui si
vous voulez savoir cela sera fait dès
mondiale de 3 ans ça vous fait un
projections raisonnables sur la capacité
de production de pétrole dans le monde
et vous avez alors ce jeu aussi avec le
roi et la fin allait peut-être lancé
adhérents
vous avez ici l'approvisionnement
pétrolier européen depuis 1965 en rose
vous avez l'introduction de la mer du
nord dont vous constatez une oblique pas
ouvertement sauf ici c'est le théorème
de lost officilelle sound from an après
l'entrée en fonction de l'angle cécile
n'a pas été franchement des producteurs
de leur bus alors il ya des gens à qui
c'est facile de faire parce que c'est
vos voisins par exemple les norvégiens
les appelait des hollandais et des
tragiques événements sociaux suffisante
épaules
donc on va leur demander et sans sa part
il me reste beaucoup plus sympa ça
marche pas
les salons choix de produits de moins en
moins alors que le prix du pétrole est
cultivé dans la 600 km et relais
multiplié par six
c'est le voisin qui sont je pense avoir
pourtant carlos lima
donc c'est que en fait la géologie a
quand même son mot à dire dans cette
histoire là vous voyez à 13 ans de
contraction de la même norme à sélestat
de 5,7 ou fait sortis du bois là vous
voyez la partie importée wendel est ce
que vous voyez c'est que depuis 2005
c'est à dire depuis que
vraisemblablement de brut conventionnel
à lasser son pic et bien les
importations européennes sont partis
alors de mise en ce qui est sûr c'est
que la production mondiale de pétrole ce
paradis croître de manière significative
depuis 2005 production du pétrole et à
qui il réclame donc les bénédictions
fait que les importations européennes
2010 11 06 la tête à toto quand vous
savez au moins 10 et moins là ça fait
moins au total l'europe aujourd'hui et
même endroit car les importations aso
jouvence alors même que la quantité de
pétrole vaut maintenant disponible en 10
min donc on a pas de dépendance
augmentation qui augmente largement
pétrolier qui au ventre la commission se
sentait et vous avez envie d'en savoir
vente et puis en simple et en plus ça et
fashion envers dans mes donc ce qui est
en berne ans comme l'apa le pétrole
vraiment le pétrole reste ce que vous
voyez c'est que le moins de pétrole
marc en 2006 à battre la crise a fait
donc égrené donc c'est vraiment pétrole
parce que vous êtes un mec génial et
l'infini si les consoles intégralement
c'est d'abord l'école et ensuite y avait
des vols et diligente gas alors le gaz
même motif même punition il ya une
quantité donnée cas sur terre donc la
production des abeilles à sa part
activement les terrains derrière
si vous avez un problème fixé par
petacchi et que le maximum devrait
suivre le maximum engagé pour les cinq à
dix ans et ce même si on voit le
développement c'est la base du graphique
des gaz qui
c'est à dire les fameux gaz de schiste
qui déchaîne dans les esprits et qui
pour l'essentiel aujourd'hui ne sont pas
des gaz de schiste mais quand vous voyez
que le gaz sénat et si je rentre voilà à
quoi ressemble la bande isolement gazier
en europe
c'est tout frais sortis du four c'est
l'estac de dp qui ont été diffusés il ya
deux jours
est ce que vous voyez c'est que comme le
pétrole
on a passé au maximum alors à la
différence du pétrole l'essentiel du gaz
en concevant d'europe bien dans l'air du
large ce gaz se transporte beaucoup plus
difficilement que le pétrole pour les
mêmes craintes qui gazouille le pétrole
et candy qui se conservent très
précieuse transportable très facilement
le gaz est en quête de ce transport
beaucoup plus difficilement il est
l'intensité capitalistique transport du
gaz très sucré et donc les gaz plus un
marché régional de marché mondiale en
général donc ce que vous voyez là c'est
que au moment où la mer du nord reste un
pic de production est bien évidemment
bien à lui aussi passé un pic et même
les scarlets et maintenant type
publiquement je vais ranger de mes
oreilles vous resterez s'est allongée a
su agen pour ce déplacement que l'europe
en contraction sertic osé prononcer ce
mot il ya une dizaine de jours et on a
perdu 10 heures ceci avec cela là aussi
on verra peut-être s'il ya des questions
illégale et que si on a un
approvisionnement gazier en correction
en europe
moi j'aimerais qu'on m'explique comment
on va faire me remplacer et dr briat ce
serment misère indépendamment de toute
considération sur le co2 et
indépendamment de toute considération
sur la jauge les défis nucléaires
je ne prends pas que ce soit possible à
quelque chose qui ressemble au niveau de
production électrique en informant je ne
pense pas que quelques centaines de
térawattheures en pays revient qu'à la
france qu'en allemagne l espagne fédéral
puisse se perd en remplaçant le nul est
apparue il ya juste et pas aussi
yamakasi alors voilà pour cent des gaz
non conventionnels les médias en
focaliser l'attention du lecteur sur un
problème qui à mon avis dans des phrases
inquiets qu'on va injecter à 2000 mètres
sous terre du mexique en conservant
l'exploitation des gaz non conventionnel
suppose de faire surface d'exploitation
aux forêts exploitées les puits 2 à 2
hectares tous les clairettes j'aimerais
qu'on m'explique ce que l'on va faire
servir du bassin parisien coûts
d'expropriation et j'aimerais qu'on
m'explique comment on va faire ça
oubliez les céréales avec
ce sont des donc je pense que si un jour
il ya des gaz non conventionnel qui sort
jamais les questions dans ce pays
ça sera quelque conscience de la
consommation actuelle de gaz à un prix
qui sera vraisemblablement deux à trois
fois par an chez de maurice au marché
européen
ça joue bien je vais bien mais que ce
soit le dira qu'il admire boulot à tout
le monde l'année prochaine
alors là je parie à marrakech 16 de
celui qui dans cette salle que ça va pas
chômer en jouer les méchants bon voilà
on ressent de la consommation changement
monde
alors vous voyez les pays ocde pour ça
at on enfin d'après la même chose depuis
40 ans et vous voyez ce fait intéressant
qui est que la consommation charme suit
l'activité économique depuis 2005 comme
le charbon sert le tiers a inventé les
centrales électriques et deux tiers du
charbon d'aliments des centrales
électriques au sentiment semblable
l'enchaînement suivant passé parle pas
encore passé de transport passé pib et
du coup la part attribuée moins
d'électricité
si je regarde la production électrique
dans tous les pays ocde elle est passée
par un maximum en 2008 2007 et depuis
elle est légèrement en dessous par très
en dessous les gentils deux racines vous
voyez que l'essentiel de l'augmentation
de la charge dans le monde s'est agi et
paraissait moyenne c'est ce que ça fait
alors maintenant je vais faire un rapide
dans les pays européens
vous avez ici la france je suis désolé
c'est jeff halpern actualisées pour 2012
mais j'ai les preuves les tableurs dans
tout les pays que je vais mettre le
milieu sous deux références en cela son
énergique mère douce où la france est
basé par maximum de consommation
énergétique en 2004 2004 c'est-à-dire
trois à quatre ans avant le début les
branchements de la fuite alors ici vous
avez le pib français depuis 1960
en données constantes sarkozy qui ne
s'est pas revenir à liens entre
l'énergie et le pib progresse
l'augmentation du pouvoir d'achat ça
marche pas on se fait sentir que l'on
comprend rien aux liens entre l'énergie
et privés robert 2% de croissance en
deux ans otage des retraites et sera
sorti enfin planté sa popularité
exactement mais c'est là qu'on renvoie
ça comment donc le à partir de 20 ans
vous voyez que la croissance zéro cela
était l'esprit que ça fait cinq ou six
dans ce n'est qu' et ça va continuer
vous savez dans l'hérault les gens qui
aiment bien la cause de la pluie espère
que laurent teaser où quelque chose aux
hobbies 14 mai quelque part entre 2014
et 2016 pour se prendre un bain donc le
voilà à part cette 21ème journée c'est
pas désagréable pour le quoi
par contre si on a besoin de votre
cahier des charges c'est à peu près sûr
que la bannière
dans la situation évoluera sauvera t
alors parlons de nos voisins tu désolé
je peux encore voir les espagnols
je commence par les italiens et donc les
italiens vous voyez que le maximum de
leur consommation énergétique s'est
produit en 2005 2006 c'est à dire avant
le début des environnements voilà nos
amis espagnols avec un maximum très
marquée en 2016
en vous rappeler que la grosse grosse
crise espagnole se devine à fond donc
c'est en 2016 et vous avez en
particulier une contraction très visible
sur le pétrole très très visible donc le
pétrole rispal il a commencé à intégrer
deux ans avant la crise espagnole et par
ailleurs quelque chose que vous notez
sur ce graphique à si vous comparez avec
le précédent record là vous voyez le
décor elle s'est inventé en italie 50 %
du mix est encore plus important en
espagne là qu'ils entendent la grèce
soixante 60 90 énergétique
il passe par un maximum en 2005 2006
2007 avant la crise
avant la crise et alors là je peux vous
dire qu'en 2012 la chute du pétrole
continuent en reste gagnant tallec en
bretagne le visage et là on voyait aussi
l'attraction sur l'ensemble charles
d'écran gaz charbon bâtiment et come
back comme des 3 diminue fortement
penser que pétrole le gaz et l'huile
vertement
c'est en 2005 et 2006 respectivement que
les états unis l'an passé
que la grande bretagne est passée aux
exportateurs importateurs de pétrole et
de gaz des cards échanges vers du nord a
fait passer la grande bretagne
exportateurs et importateurs de pétrole
égard 2005 et 2006 là ils avaient la
manie alors l'allemagne à la
réunification qu'il est bien à diminuer
cinq entités notamment chambre quand
vous voyez dans les années qui ont suivi
la réunification tellement pétrole
contre tellement gaz le nucléaire est à
peu près stable jusqu'en 2006 m en 2006
luc bertrand pacé courbet 2011 à salé en
fait car l'événement un peu brutal sur
une tendance qui avait commencé avant et
là je m'attends de vous montrer les
statistiques film sur l'électricité
c'est sur mon site pour ceux que ça
intéresse mais sachez que depuis 2006 ou
en fait depuis le début de son flanc
renouvelables la bague n'a pas
substituer essentiellement des fossiles
de la substitut est essentiellement
nucléaire par de l'électricité en plein
c'est essentiel du clergé la substitut
et quasiment pas de petits tracas envie
d'allaiter fossiles en allemagne est
restée stable
et enfin voici l'union européenne prise
dans son ensemble et en 2012 nous aurons
souffre 2011 et larmoyant pour ceux à
qui ce monde et barber acompte qualité
qui a démarré en totalité à paris au
début des années 90 avaient cours est
alors vers le bar vraiment
et voilà que l'artiste vous voyez il ya
tout juste un an
est ce que quelqu'un de lettres de
schiste schistes 2012 et qu'en dessous
de 11 vous dire des trucs que j'ai
regardé démissionné de ses fonctions de
vidange est ce que vous voyez les gens
donc moi ce que je vois c'est comme
d'habitude au journal c'est d'en faire
la différence entre sa joie miracle
aussi je devrais pas dans les états unis
il n'y a pas de racaille schiste des
états unis qui ont un petit soubresaut
voilà un autre agent cinq ans j'étais là
le 10 ou 11 ans voilà l'ensemble de
lancer des oeufs et voilà mon copain
cher et leurs copains talent là
l'histoire tout à fait différente et
vous voyez que la différence tous les
pays qu'ils viennent passer pour
endosser les lieux où le pépin y arriver
chez eux ces chansons typiques de ce
qu'on avait dans les séries un siècle
c'est-à-dire un pays angola des
spécialisations les gens se déplacent
moins construisent plus voilà je vais
vous raconter prendre tout ce qui n'a
quand même pour finir cette histoire
donc la première partie de cet exposé
c'est l'europe est dos au mur
l'énergie fossile fédrigo de vivre qu'on
a appelée à s'exciter dare-dare sur la
question des énergies possibles parce
que sinon c'est les convenants qui nous
attend et donc le taux des taxes
le premier à les avoir en fait qui sait
ça s'est passé pour 2004 avec les
attaques se faire passer tout est dit
très exactement ça enfin de conclusion
évidente si j'avais laissé au hasard
trois jeux à 2 et il était un peu plus
explicite
dans sa conclusion donc on avait adhéré
à cette idée sérieusement sur ce sujet
et c'est comme ça je pense que par
ailleurs on prend la meilleure option de
s'occuper très sérieusement la gestion
du changement climatique qu'ils y
aillent à a+ contre vous poser quelques
petits désagréments cela m'embête
alors pour ça je vais vous donner
quelques petites images vous avez tous
entendu dire que les délégations
température moyenne on pourrait avoir
dans le monde pareil climat qui se
réchauffe significativement ses quatre
comparses au printemps pourri du
vendredi on sera bien content d avoir à
vous signale que nous on n'a peut-être
pas il ya des gens ailleurs qui les ont
d'une manière caractéristique du
changement climatique pour élaborer la
vente étant donné le temps 30° au padre
quand la police est quand même
car est pas tous les quatre matins c'est
juste que le système dépressionnaire
l'anticipent modératrice positionné que
l'on avait l'air plein d'offres à venir
pour sa créance
et si on fait la moyenne sûr que c'était
bien une situation très strict alors je
reviens à ce que vous vous avez écrit ce
à quoi ressemble ce bateau ce qu'on
appelle les la végétation climatique et
vous voyez considère pas d'or
l'essentiel d'europe gap de forêt par
don en nature
il ya juste un endroit qu'on ne peut pas
assez sur ces cinq facteurs limitants
ici là où vous auriez des statines ont
partout ailleurs et placé faut que vous
n'ayez les armes
et s'il vous est coupée et chanteur
voilà à quoi ressemble vraiment il ya
vingt dix ans vous avez au coeur les
attaques arabes lasserre qui fait voir
qu il fait plus froid
vous avez des locks qui sont posées la
vie n'est alors qu'il avait déposée sur
la scandinavie comme il est plus fort
qu'il fût sec c'est plus sexy
alors elle joue elle a pu s'échouer dans
un tipi j'ai vu sec et du coup y'a pas
de pluie pour rayer la forêt vous avez
des réserves un bien là d'un pas les
sinon le reste de l'europe et dans un
climat beaucoup trop sec
pour gagner vos invitations s'agit de
pâtures s'agit de deux agents et lille
avant vous n'avez pas un système
agricole possible dans ce genre là et
enfin londres constituent ces carottes
glaciaires qui est prélevé dans l'isère
a tellement de cet art et celles qui
étaient sur le canada que le niveau de
l'océan a baissé sans l'accord passé
entre 120 et bien la différence entre
les deux gars que j'ai à vous présenter
ces 5 2
c'est juste 5 degrés est à terre si je
présente les choses autrement
voilà comment a évolué la température
moyenne de la planète depuis la mi temps
est ce que vous voyez sur ce graphique
c'est que en indiquant la température
qui était de 3,4 degrés plus fois
qu'aujourd'hui s'est réchauffée jusqu'à
voir les rôles des parents mais en gros
vous avez pris à l'état d'assam degrés
pour faire cette transition là et vous
l'avez fait que vous voyez en dit me
romain donc une des glaciations ce qui
fait passer la carte marine de gauche
dans ce que je vous ai montré un carte
graphique droite c'est 4 à 5 degrés en
disant voilà maintenant les nations
température que nous avons regardé
siècle alors trouver autre chose
nous sommes encore très loin d'en avoir
une conséquence nous avons encore très
loin dans la formule est cohérent et
voilà qu'on rêve si on veut défendre un
changement
si on suit cette trajectoire la sape
oscar à la question de savoir milliards
d'euros avec espérance de vie par la
gérante dire ça enlève 10 53 cents j'ai
pas vous dire c'est qu'avec cinq ou
cinquante ans d'espérance de vie par an
je peux vous assurer c'est simple dès la
ccin terrain appliquera à la vente par 7
et 10 milliards de minutes et vander
l'ayant strictement aucune envie de
partir avec leur groupe leur école ou un
changement des habitudes culturelles
surtout pour les avis d ailleurs
s'appliquerait à 7 à 10 milliards
l'habitude sédentaires perturbations de
l'environnement qui sera ingérable dans
le loyer et comme c'est une expérience
grandeur nature que nous faisons pour la
première fois on peut imaginer ce que
peuvent être les conséquences
je ne peux donner quelques exemples on
peut surtout pas imaginer ce que ça sera
bon dans les exemples on peut donner et
dégradation des écosystèmes sahariens
absolument évident qu'il va y avoir une
augmentation de la diversité des agents
pathogènes qui a dit à chaleur il va y
avoir une montée du niveau de l'eau ce
truc là va s'exercer avec les événements
de type cimetière katrina c'est comme ça
que va s'exercer dans la montée du
niveau de l'eau ça rapproche doucement
les infrastructures de bord de mer du
niveau de l'eau et à l'occasion du maïdo
d'une parfaite et c'est là toute façon
sera fixée débordé vous avez un
traitement discrète qui me fiche de
l'enfant c'est ça ce que va avoir comme
effet avec des niveaux d'eau c'est pas
l'appareil monte là
gentiment autres serviette les porte
parole de ban ki moon c'est l'idée qu'on
a souvent rigolo
vite il faut que la rafinerie vous la
voulez parler sa serviette le port non
départ de sa serviette la voiture
affaire grave au départ avec sa
serviette entre vaud ou des pagnes sa
serviette la centrale était surtout cap
n'est pas sérieux donc et si vous avez
comme au japon par exemple dans le camp
c'est un tsunami qui a causé le problème
si vous avez un vase marine qui vous
fiche de bazar électrique quel que soit
le mode de production électrique parce
que japon il est clair qu'ils ont
concerné où elles vendent plus que ça
fait derrière ça fait un tout petit
quelque chose sur le pib et sur
l'espérance de vie de rire personne
alors pour un capes dévoilons pas
d'énergie sous le pied il est évident si
ce genre d'événement arrive alors on est
en décroissance énergétique rapide la
capacité grenoble avait pas il va y
avoir une variabilité du climat qui va
augmenter notamment sur les épisodes
caniculaires
vous allez avoir une modification de la
circulation
en chêne cet avis de vastes et enfin les
événements extrêmes qu'ils font déposer
avant les événements extrêmes surtout en
étant d'aller loin dans l'égypte il ya
une question qui est posée sur le
groenland et l'antarctique de l'ouest il
ya une question pas connu du tout sur la
signification de l'eau parce qu'une
partie du co2 que des ponts dans l'aisne
est repris par les océans pour mais ce
niveau il faut savoir que le ph des
océans était à peu près stable aux
alentours de 8 depuis 25e année ça ne
fait pas de servion d'années que le père
de l'océan c'est valable entre 8,1 plus
quelque chose et vite
un rejet qui est le plus et moins seront
deux points de perdre on est là on est
en train de parler de modifier l'acidité
de l'océan jusqu'à potentiellement un
point de péage de 850 personnes que
c'est ce que sa fille marine personne
est en train il ya les stocks de carbone
qui pourraient se mobiliser dans le sol
et c'est pour aller dans ces substances
la seule chose je viens de vous dire en
ce qui concerne le changement climatique
c'est que cette expérience avec le temps
va nous réserver à une croissance
surprise et vous savez là sur félix
année après ses insultes ne voulez pas
vous dire quand les portes a été la
conséquence de la grosse survie ce matin
donc le changement climatique
c'est quelque chose qu'il faut
absolument gérer la grosse difficulté du
changement climatique c'est que nous
vivons aujourd'hui dans des systèmes
insouciante qui s'appelle la démocratie
sahpresa fait parce que c'est des
systèmes insouciante associant mais du
coup il ya un contrecoup à ce système
la radio en main et se jugent pas de ce
genre de problème voilà je vais finir
par là que j'ai commencé comme nous
sommes en traction aussi l'amélioration
que nous avons paradoxalement consoler
ceux qui marchent t'occuper de notre
balance commerciale en europe
dit autrement s'il est des carburants
l'économie pour des motifs impérieux de
son cardio court terme pour éviter
d'avoir un système social qui ces fonds
etc
c'est comme ça que nous avons la
meilleure option de trouver les systèmes
qui vaut bien les votes d'organisation
qui m'ont bien les réseaux francs qui
vont bien les règles économiques qui
vont bien bien évidemment les joujoux
des pays qui vont bien pour faire en
sorte que gérald tremblay et socke sort
puisque l'homme est un animal domestique
que nous avons à mon avis la meilleure
chance d'entraîner le reste tout le
monde dans cette équipe c'est en faisant
ça chez nous sans rien demander à
personne stationnement des bombes sûrs
que nous appelons la meilleure option en
prenant le meilleur sur un jeu blanc de
vendeur ça ça va faire très plaisir
le liquid si vous voulez rayonner la
totalité des logements en france il ya
prétend bihan logements qui sont à peu
près de 1 700 m² par logement et il faut
quelques centaines d'euros par mètre
carré pour rénover un logement
on parle de 10 milliards et si là dedans
on y tient à la moitié qui sont pas
construits la vie folle pour les
castésiens construire ailleurs sur les
vitres sans pédaler je voulais savoir de
à croire elle vous le fait à paris
bilingue vous avez remis 30 millions
véhicules qui circulent sur la route
le prix d'achat d'un véhicule
sympathique
aux villes je voulais faire à main
histoire qu'on me dise pas que c'est
donc sans miséreux 600 milliards d'euros
pour remplacer si en plus vous devez
électrifié des autoroutes rld et les
trains il y avait deux fois il y des
référés l'enfance de sens que l'on a
aujourd'hui à peu près 100 et de voile
et 1280 innocence
donc si vous voir faire des fils ou de
daraya smur bière avec des petits
véhicules qui permettent de se déplacer
dans le coin le les tickets sur cette
affaire se valent entre 2000 et 4000
yards en faut des gardes et les process
industriels
il faut avec les rentrées de caresses
une phase aller entendu de centaines de
milliards
à mon avis pour se débarrasser des
combustibles fossiles sans effondrement
social et déjà avec une diminution
significative du pib
déjà culte ification team diminution
significative des tp il faut doubler la
corruption écrit décarbonés alors là
deux options ou bien vous aimez bien
vulgaire c'est d'après 300 milliards
d'euros
ou bien vous l'aimez pas right round 5
est vide c'est un calcul une indication
pour monter ma propre en déconnant
l'allemagne bien fait rire qu il ya pas
longtemps a dépensé à ce jour à peu près
300 milliards d'euros pour faire 18 % de
son électricité avec des votes de
production locale la bande à 10% dans la
biomasse est déjà moins millions
d'hectares alors il faut pas du maïs
pour
l'arbre pour les ports font du maïs pour
les pénaliser ils ont un million
d'hectares de maïs fourrage en allemagne
qu'il faut directement les catalyseurs
pour faire de l'électricité des gardiens
bon c'est ce que je vous ai tout à
l'heure l'énergie renouvelable
elle est propre mais l'éthique quand
elle était petite elle se met à avoir
des inconvénients comme toutes les
énergies et la question des tarifs et
les avantages et les inconvénients donc
300 milliards c'est-à-dire nucléaire
pour faire 10 8% de l'électricité est
rare qui renouvelle sa 25 ans soit la
durée de vie au vietnam à savourer
atteindre donc s'il voulait être
totalement décarbonés leur électricité
sur 60 ans il faudrait km 5 6 milliards
d'euros et comme là dedans je vous ai
oublié étudié au fond de la baltique
dans les arbres pour faire 100 gigawatts
que cela pouvait aller aussi 6 à 10
milliards en version argent il a dans ce
débat goûter un recul qui est en
contraction énergétique la productivité
du travail va laisser sa copine avant
doivent augmenter
il a évidemment encore augmenter les
factures
voilà mais moi j'avais mon cas
démocratie donc si en parfaite
connaissance de cause
le vam dit nucléaire il en est pas
question
5 milliards il faut juste comprendre que
c'est à peu près ça lors de vendeurs
nous avons un voilà après pour aller
dans cette direction
c'est alors un truc que je vais pas
rappeler mais c'est évident entre cette
direction là et qu'une économie un peu
les chinois c'est à dire que l'on se
remet à transpirer pour construire
reconstruire et du conte en transpire
mois pour faire le dvd est titulaire et
les iphone
donc c'est une économie dans laquelle on
encaisse délibérément en orientant la
baisse de voir jean paul fischer
l'essentiel est de 69 ans de travail
sont rentrés vers le fait l'autre
alternative c'est que le pointage à 5 on
est dans une société qui se désagrégera
avec des inégalités qui l'ont fortement
croissante c'est à dire que les doux et
ceux qui s'affolent or on sait l'argent
c'est la russie qu'aux de chute du mur
c'est à dire que les ballons abbas sur
le dos des autres
les autres voient leur espérance de vie
baisser langnau be baissé pendant que
les quêtes le ballet des oligarques
parce que maintenant sur la côte d'azur
c'est à peu près ça va donner la russie
post soviétique avait convaincu les 30
ou 40 %
c'est à mon avis ça que nous attend si
on se fie pas
environ les élites en bande son est
coupé parce qu'elle a senti notre monde
des lumières belle mais c'est à mon avis
ce genre de truc qui vous attendent
l'autre option c'est de tout le monde
ceux disparus
il a fallu faire des ports et aux jambes
si on pense aussi à la tête de la voie à
suivre alors je lance que leurs ordres a
tous les atouts dans sa manche
ça fait très longtemps que milliard
contre 1 séronais l'europe et un pic des
faillites une zone densément peuplée
depuis longtemps fait le mans dotés en
ressources naturelles donc exploiter au
mieux ce que nous avons il ya longtemps
que c'est notre code génétique des
européennes soit dit en passant c'est
aussi pour la même raison que c est
depuis longtemps un japonais
donc ça nous avons nous avons conçu des
modes d'organisation qui sont adaptés à
ce genre de truc d'un consul des
techniques qui sont adoptés avant le
truc que l'apathie et les coeurs de
villes qui sont appelées à changer enfin
et c'est là qu'on a fait ça parce que
c'était il ya eu parmi ceux ci avec cela
on est plutôt pas mauvais quand il
s'agit de se creuser la cervelle
on est très bon m par contre sur la
papier koldyke on a le sens des
infrastructures
quand on parle de l'europe
et en particulier de la france aurait qu
on nous envie facilement d'autres
incarnent des valeurs plus enfants qu'on
ait dans les deux hôpitaux qui quoi
qu'on en dise il vient et c'est donc on
sait faire ce genre de trucs
par contre ce qu'on ne sait pas faire
c'est essayer de copier les américains
en pensant que le projet va héberger
boussole est l'un des trucs à mon avis
qui me font appel au prc français que
l'europe est juste à replonger
l'économie de marché physique et que ça
ne peut pas être un projet de conquête
de la lune conjointe
on apprend donc aujourd'hui je pense que
l'urgence vous savez que l'europe a
démarré sur les enjeux énergétiques la
communauté européenne du charbon et de
l'acier
laura top donc l'europe s'est faite sur
des anges ressources sociales et
d'énergie il faut il revenir en chine
est urgent d'y revenir
parce que s'il pense que c'est dans la
black on suit aujourd'hui en disant au
libéralisme et puis ça que ça ira bien
et on va faire un rival qui pourrait
changer avec les états unis etc
je pense que c'est juste que tu n'as pas
faire aujourd'hui c'est à dire
respiration sida à paris des problèmes
et je ne dis pas ça parce que je suis un
affreux protectionnisme qui marche et
s'est fait remplacer pour le marché et
je suis pas du tout confortable avec ce
qui a été fait des journalistes donc le
mais par contre il faut mettre de
marcher d'un pas lent ça passe donc pour
faire des carottes les vrais problèmes
par contre pour faire des mandats
infrastructures et piloté de dégâts car
pense aux filières sont l'espagne je
pense que l'espagne un besoin urgent
vente et l'espagne à bâtir une économie
fragile sur le pétrole c'est l écologie
du bdp l'économie du tourisme
elle a quitté les colonies qui faisait
sa force quelque part notamment avec un
poêle à pétrole extrêmement fort
l'espagne a une ressource précieuse avec
le soleil c'est peut-être quelque chose
qu'il faut savoir exploiter
l'espagne c'est faire des avions et des
centrales nucléaires de poing exactement
quand la france est exactement comme
donc je vois nouveau que l'espagne se
disent que paradoxalement ce qui est
entrain de l'arrière en scorant il faut
qu'elle en profite
exactement comme le romanche salle et
peut-être que paradoxalement le pays est
moins bien armé pour saisir cette
occasion qui nous est donné c'est la
bague parce que l'allemagne est encore
probable santé quelques bars pour avoir
envie de changer de collège
par ailleurs l'espagne arrive aux plus
jeunes enfin été pressenti
j'étais en espagne et d'un pays plus
jeune que l'allemagne est donc je pense
que la france a intérêt à aller chercher
plus au sud qu'au nord pour examen mais
après notre intérêt à aller chercher au
sud remontent en dehors allez on va dire
quelque chose qui permette de rebondir
dans le contexte actuel on a débordé
morère habitude mais j'imagine question
merci on va massivement en question un
peu la géniale passer le micro
voilà
parce que comme angélique et vous tous
que vous présentez il me semble qu'on en
parle absolument pas dans la société
française dans un peu par défaut les
élections n'en a pas parlé quand on
parle de tout et économique pour que ce
que votre approche et si le partage et
la société française
je vais vous donner une définition assez
satisfait que le pense valable au succès
international et national c'est un sujet
du 20 heures de tf1
cahuzac c'est par des nationales bh
c'est un sujet national
un truc qui n'est pas au 20 heures de
tf1 c'est pas un sujet national peut
insulter nationale pourquoi est-ce que
ce sujet d'un animal dans les médias à
ce que les médias si certains entre les
pratiques un peu vous dirai ce que je
veux dire mon pape au mandat de refléter
le monde tel qu'il est et ils sont pour
mandat de répondre à des sollicitations
d'autres porteurs d'intérêts
quand vous regardez les readers et
reprend bien sûr précisé à 90% des
matières premières qui font les
rangements d'oser des pêches a ajouté la
dépêche afp se fait rarement est ce pas
insulter les journalistes qui sont lents
collecte les formes en exprimant à ce
beau tableau la dépêche afp se fait sur
sollicitation extérieure nous envoyer un
communiqué de presse
vous pouvez être un tabou recherche
comme vous pouvez être un parti
politique comme vous et m l'entreprise
espère avoir payé presque quand je
servirai pas important c'est ça la
première qui fait que vous avez
informations 80
l'histoire par coeur il aura besoin de
faire un thé en gros si vous remarquez
que vous faites une information dont 90
% de ce que va faire la fpc les
sollicitations externe 90% cette affaire
journaux c'est bien pour ça que vous
avez entre 3 journaux télévisés de
grands chênes ou en ce 3 quotidien j'ai
trouvé le sujet du jour parce que la
rationalité des appartements où je vous
ai dit ça la quête de la vérité malpas
de fonctionnement du journalisme en
scène mode de fonctionnement du
journaliste française est vraiment là
les sollicitations extérieures et les
sollicitations externes sont faites par
des gens qui ont envie de dire quelque
chose
les gens ont envie de faire passer est
déréglée chiffrer son art
beaucoup vous avez les enseignants de
ces papiers offert le comité presse à
payer m'enseigner presse les années les
ingénieurs dans les entreprises mais en
général ils sont payés pour faire passer
la vérité chiffré rabattront et non pas
qu'on voit ensuite il a envie de la
perdre et extérieure et ses experts à
les seuls qui sont un peu payé pour
faire passer les vérités chiffres et
c'est les laboratoires de recherche
donc sauf que dans ce que je vous ai
exposé quand il y à darche h actifs sur
le sujet vous avez une information qui
circule typiquement changement
climatique de l'information circule
parce que garde la recherche les fake
médias chercheurs tout mettre sur la
paille
c'est même de se vouer beaucoup parce
qu'il a fait dans le monde scientifique
essentiellement en dehors voire fois et
donc il est dans deux couches aussi
publié dans le monde
dans le monde de l'énergie toute
information est détenue par des acteurs
privés et donc il fixe avant résumé rang
touche dans les opérateurs comme hergé
qu'il a des données d'exploitation sur
la totalité des gisements pétroliers
mondiaux car l'intérêt à faire un
communiqué presse en disant je prévois
tête haute et un sur les gisements
pétroliers en exploitation dans les
années qui viennent pour qu'ils ne sont
pas donc c'est maintenant si jean dauby
si il ya des journalistes et des élus
l'europe était en déclin plus courrier
l'autre il faudrait que ce soit je
partais des avis c'est très important
lors des derniers acteurs de ça il
faudrait qu'à partis politiques disent
les gens en face à des grands vignobles
sont venus passer leur tour d comme tous
les partis centristes c'est partout vous
avez un
vous avez un outil qui s'excitent ergote
sur ce sujet dans la sphère du politique
c'est yves cochet qui n'est même pas
encore de l'hiver voilà à part lui il
n'y a pas un parlementaire qui
s'intéresse de près donc le favori n ya
pas le héros locaux chante en allemand
mais vous avez les dames un sujet
correspondent à ça l'étape suivante pour
la course à celui là est
particulièrement ennuyeux parce que j'ai
essayé de vous exposer que nous en
étions tous parce que l'iran dément ceci
avec cela comme le monde politique
réagit essentiellement à des porteurs
d'intérêts n'est pas essentiellement à
la formation rationnelle pour
s'incruster dans le place dans les
débats publics
ce qui compte c'est ce que pensent des
jambes
ces basses ce qui correspond à
l'observation des faits si tout le monde
pense que le nucléaire sont vides en
championnat en rond dans le superman du
terrain sur les charbons le sujet
d'attention à se raconter les uns vivent
soit donc le et si les gens pensent le
zoom en vite les ans soit enchères et 20
des centres parce qu'ils sont ils pas de
savoir si on va plus loin
donc le briser
exactement dans la sarthe donc les
débats se parler parce qu'il est porteur
d'intérêt ne sont pas après il ya une
deuxième raison qui est que traiter de
ce sujet dans le monde des médias 106 et
si je vous disais la route gros points
résumé ce que je viens de raconter en
technique caractères espaces compris
c'est parce que vous feriez c'est pas
immédiat pourtant ces cinq lois
journaliste caractères espaces compris
ceinture donc le vitriol donc le sujet
un sujet qui ne peut progresser que de
manière lente quand tous les sujets
compliqués et qui est que si on trouve
vraiment détenteurs d'intérêts les moins
de 7 ans si tu vois ce que j'essaie de
faire un gauchiste
j'ai pas encore acquis
avec moi mais c'est s'agit de
transformer un certain nombre
d'entreprises qui vont intéresser
karine leur intérêt mais aussi son
entreprise s'est pas pliée je vous
prends un exemple pierre joye vous avez
à ce que vous faites des barrages du
groupe d derrière cette île singulière
d'état valérie létard ou fait sa chambre
cette étreinte de nos routes et à
l'arrière garde bleue qu'est-ce qu'ils
ont vidés
est ce que je dis à ces voiles accueilli
ce matin est là pour faire en sorte que
ce sujet ait du mal à dégager alors un
dernier point les inciteraient vu que
les médias français c'est beaucoup moins
vrai dans d'autres pays comme les médias
français sont désargentés c'est en
général les journalistes qui traitent et
militants et scientifiques dans le
morbihan demande à ces mêmes
il se trouve que en termes de
disponibilité le militant est souvent
disponible avant scientifique il est
payé pour ça
donc si vous avez un sujet sur la
réglementation des produits chimiques
vous allez trouver porte-parole de
l'union des industries chimiques en un
quart d'heure les trous et baker et
glissant un quart d'heure et le
professeur du sluc qui à l'école
nationale de santé doit être fait
l'énergie qui vont bien il est parti en
voyage est l'heure pour les schémas où
vous devrez donc alors vous l'avez su
nous fait l'édition de la toile et a
rejoint lors des 6es dans l'actualité
n'allait pas donc les gens que vous
allez voir s'exprimer sur ce sujet sont
en général des militants par les
scientifiques
ils peuvent ou pas être en accord avec
la science des logos et des deux peuples
c'est à dire que vous avez un certain
nombre de dossiers dans lesquels la
vérité scientifique et du côté du
militant à coadout côtés d'industriels
et j'avais des dossiers dans lesquels il
n'y a pas pas d'absolution des rôles qui
soit beau jeu donc c'est voilà du coup
ça donne un jeu complètement illisibles
très difficile à décrypter pour le moral
et on en revient à ce que cette étude à
l'heure bourrel envoyant dans les sables
les enjeux de la transition énergétique
mais ils ont chacun leur définition ils
sont pour la transition énergétique à
condition de rien à voir on trouvait à
l'écart des matières premières va pas
bien et je vais finir par la décote dans
le cadre du débat national
il y avait un groupe de travail qui
était censé plancher sur le respect des
engagements rigole c'est comme ça que je
le dise pour sa chorale et pose la
question
la question était comment atteindre le
mix énergétique pour 2025
quand vous savez le mix énergétique
les respecter nos engagements un tir du
cubage aujourd'hui sont depuis
d'existence il n'y a plus aucun accord
international contraignant sur les
histoires qui marque juste engagé à
rester dans marcheurs ouvert des côtes
américaines entre en sortir et 7/10 part
à quel niveau réduction des origines se
dit plus donc on a un accord moral de
l'apec soit moralement car il a pas
triché osé d'orge et remplace est le
seul chiffre qui avait d'ailleurs que
volant céder sur l'île hier le mix
énergétique en 2025
la seule question quantique et sait
comment est ce que je suis pour le sang
le groupe de travail a répondu lu entre
les lignes mais ne parle pas on n'est
pas dans un débat entre gens qui revient
longuement filmé dans toute démarche
les séances fois c'est un acteur
essentiel à garder en tête les médias
n'ont pas un rôle dans la fédé le
conteneur wall retraités confrontation
date est toujours là qui sont issus
jveux an selon la première comment une
démocratie on va dire qui est très bien
noté juste devant par les médias
l'opinion publique qui fait les élus les
celtic communes et aux racines de s'en
sortir
sur la base de ce que vous allez
présenter et si la bulle et pourra
changer les choses
le délai qu'il est chère la dm alors
chaque type d'action a toujours en
regardent d'une échelle géographique
delà d'un périmètre des décisions de la
réserve dans un fonds qui est ce qu'il
est vous pouvez vous à votre niveau des
idées n'est pas du reste de changer de
lieu de changer de métier de changer
maison ça ne nous est pas descendre
comme il ya la prévision du changement
climatique des ménages mais en suède et
je m'installe en suède comme je crois
des banques après avoir des actions
concertées à vous pouvez avoir des coups
et en créant une entreprise avec des
gens vers une action vous réactivité le
cas le cera il n'y a pas du tout unique
contestable par contre si je si je
prends de questions parce qu'elle était
vraiment comment faire en sorte que les
instances nationales
j'imagine que vous aviez l'air la terre
commence à s'exciter sérieux point sur
le sujet eh bien mon sentiment c'est que
la démocratie prend le problème à
l'envers simple quand on est habitué à
ce qui a toujours été un chef dans une
tribune animaux c'est à dire
il s'impose parce qu'il est plus fort à
la plus intelligente nous est derrière
de ton père est bien la démocratie
entretient une ambivalence très forte
avec ce qu'elle appelle ses dirigeants
qui sont en fait beaucoup plus proche
des exécuteurs des starter est donc
comme c'est les exécuteurs
testamentaires
si on se perd à dos au carré avec son
voeu ça voudra pas la tête
hollande et la croissance parce que
l'essentiel du genre demande et ils ont
pas coupé qu'aujourd'hui on le rappeler
est allé à la prêtrise en plus il
continue à la demande et parce qu'ils ne
comprennent pas ce qu'on va faire ce
n'est pas maintenant qu'il reste donc le
studio rien qu'à lui conserve donc le
selon le pouvoir national en fait ils
reflètent impression la base
contrairement à l'idée qu'on s'en fait
au lieu d'arriver des grandes visions
l'essentiel du temps alors comment
est-ce qu'on imprime un mouvement de la
base mon sentiment c'est que y'a 2 il ya
deux trois canaux qui alors hein y'a
papa ya une semaine
dit autrement si les sujets que j'ai
évoquées à berne quelque chose
d'irrémédiable les deux à trois ans qui
viennent
par contre si vous raisonnez en
s'interdisant les choses qui ont une
influence c'est ce que j'appelle les
corps intermédiaires donc les camps
intermédiaire c'est des décideurs
économiques
si vous en avez revenus croissants qui
disent la sauvegarde cause excité
sérieusement tu es nous on est d'accord
parce que ça va faire rentrer à faire ça
je les choses
si vous avez toujours les corps
intermédiaires une fraction croissante
du monde académique qui commencent à
faire entendre une voix qui est des mecs
il faut s'exciter sérieusement sur la
question parce que ce qui s'est passé
dans le climatique a lancé un impact
aussi là le problème c'est que l'on voit
par le monde académique est considéré
comme légitime sur ce genre de problème
comique n'est pas outillé en traiter un
cadre magnifique et comme il a une forme
souvent les économistes ont un problème
d'ego plus important techniciens et donc
le fait de se faire déposséder devant
les caméras de télévision ou une partie
de cette troisième à ses compétences
donc c'est ça va être difficile ce qui
va pouvoir se faire c'est que des jeunes
qui ne se sont pas en fermant s'invite
sur ce terrain là commence à faire de
l'économie physique qui en avait
quelques-uns et ce qu'ils ont déjà
pignon sur rue savez c'est compliqué de
faire changer parce que je ne place
acquise qui n'ont pas envie de laisser
filer que l'on va gagner c'est compliqué
paradoxalement cette affaire est d'après
vous avez ce qu'on appelle le bon
citoyen et d'un citoyen de savoir
particulier en association alors les
grandes associations environnementales
malheureusement n'êtes pas dans ce
problème parce qu'elles ont une écurie
geek des problèmes les cantons avec
lecture high rider problème nouvelle
proposé aucune solution puisque une
solution dans cette histoire c'est à
dire archives
payant et ça sert de l'économie
l'économie son rôle se classer ça sert à
ça
si vous n'êtes pas capable de placer et
que vous dites je veux en même temps me
débarrasser des héros gêne parce que ça
gâche le paysage des centrales
nucléaires parce que c'est dangereux les
incinérateurs parce que sa pub des
villes parce que ceux-ci êtes vous
débarrassera toute la question c'est
louise est pas plus a lancé les amendes
10 public l'air cause les éoliennes mais
naturalisé à haute tension depuis l'aube
à troyes
le gomme environnementales les
malheureusement aujourd'hui pas
configuré comme un proposant il est
configuré comme une opposante et du coup
certains avaient compliqué si on veut le
mettre dans les processus de gestion des
fois il accélère et il ya un certain
nombre d'exemples où le dossier ne
débouche pas de ça je pense tous les
sens que le monde environnementale a sa
part de responsabilité dans le fait
qu'on est qualifié qu'en cas d'échec on
restreint des chefs d'état les 17 ans
d'échec c'est donc le le jeune acteur
parfois expliqué par contre je pense que
les grandes associations qui pourraient
commencer à bouger sur ce problème c'est
les associations s'agit par là bas donc
l'abbé pierre
les uns sans frontières à tous les gens
qui ont un objet social reconnu et qui
disent aux messieurs chers face aux
problèmes là on va se retrouver avec des
conséquences que ce problème qui doit
être absolument ingérable sache je suis
pas sûr que ça va arriver facilement
mais je pense que c'est quelque chose au
6 rue à quatre reprises est-ce que c'est
tous ces gens là par action stable sont
des pantins intérêts c'est en relation
des porteurs d'intérêts
si le président de médecins sans
frontières commence à répéter tous les
quatre pattes arrangera bleus font
vraiment s'occuper sérieusement la
question du changement climatique parce
que sinon on oublie ça y compris en
belgique
oui dans une question qu'il y ait
effectivement à cette ressource
d'énergie l'évolution de nos sociétés
qui en dépendent
que pensez-vous de la borde d'études et
de travaux comme ceux aux risques qu'ils
voient dans l'import de nouvelles
technologies et de cette
décentralisation est mise en réseau des
possibilités de trouver d'autres
solutions pour régler effectivement une
société totalement ouvert alors on va
revenir à ce que j'ai évoquée au début
de cette intervention
ce qui à faire diffusion de masse des
objets que nous avons et m la cervelle
fait la conception de l'objet sa
diffusion c'est une affaire l'énergie le
fait aujourd'hui on est tous ça ça
devant beaucoup plus d'énergie que le
fait qu'on ait le temps de le partager
sur un angle est à 100 femmes pourtant
on est passé d'un ordinateur central
augmente
maillard ah ça marche mieux mais ça
c'est une tonne de co2 par personne pour
le fabriquer une utilisation sécuritaire
une tonne de co2 par personne pour le
faire mais qui est la cause de
l'empreinte carbone des français entre
1990 et 2010 c'est à dire la
contrepartie de la consommation des
français et pour les deux tiers du a5
une décision donc l'ajout des
technologies de l'information qui vous
fait j'essaie en vain carbone des
françaises taaf et aux bandes
jusqu'à maintenant la démocratisation
des usages toujours aller avec le fait
que je n'avais plus d'énergie
la voiture d'aujourd'hui est vachement
plus efficace que la voiture ya 50 ans
mais on consomme pour plus de pétrole
dans les voitures giraud plus de l'autre
justement de presque 7 efficace si
aujourd'hui on voulait prendre l'avion à
chuter la consommation globale des
avions sur les considérablement
inférieur à ce qui est donc le bleu la
diffusion intervient alors heureusement
il dit on décentralise et sarah des
problèmes je pense qu'ils se trouvent
deux fois je pense qu'il ne se trompe
d'une première fois et ça renvoie la
question qui a été posée tout à l'heure
parce que face à des problèmes nouveaux
tout ne peut pas être géré un des
chemins je devrais dire et ça c'est la
première bondir
gouvernance locale beatty foule je pense
que oui et non je pense que d'édicter
des normes nationales sur la taille des
carottes ce que vous trouvez au marché
c'est une connerie
par contre je pense que surtout ciel dès
demain juin
par contre je pense que si il y avait de
place pour un pilotage national et des
investissements partagés entre tottenham
et je vais prendre à des gens très
précis qui est solide elle était si des
différences entre autres
l'édification et production oui oui
alors maintenant je prends l'exemple de
l'électricité si vous passez le
nucléaire aux panneaux solaires pour
produire la même quantité d'électricité
vous avez besoin de mettre 50 à 100 ans
plus tard soit un problème
je ne crois pas que ça soit de nature à
vous permettre de gérer plus facilement
un problème
l'hiver est très contraint les poissons
le faire pour vous donc je pense que
rifkin sa théorie elle est tout à fait
anti économique
par contre là que les vaches
montbéliardes - ce qui va réussir à
distancer campillo
non pas qu'elle aurait sept chats mais
en fait tu devrais pas dire ça parce que
c'est une erreur de business
probablement pas spectacle comme les
dons car c'est ça est derrière
d'ailleurs une partie des élus rend plus
que ça très sérieusement un jour le
problème parce qu'il vaut mieux raconter
doivent donc je te vois la décence ainsi
la correction électrique c'est d'étudier
les besoins en capitaux je vous dis par
votre entassant ce qui veut dire si je
prends vraiment vers le si vous allez
sans digard a dépensé et bien si vous
décentraliser la corruption et les tic à
l'arrivée de l'écran voir un violeur par
contour décentralisée production
électrique vient des pertes en ligne
tout le monde le sait les centrales sont
pas toujours à proximité des lieux de
production de conserves
vous traversez la france se racheter
devant internet
heureusement heureusement pour un
certain nombre de gens
donc pas ce que je peux dire c'était 50
concentré problème c'est de bon sens sur
les autres qu'à acheter après il faut
savoir que les moyens d'y décentralisée
passer certaines quantités plus les
augmenter vous avez un truc dans un pays
et qu'il faut savoir pour injecter sur
le réseau soit en basse tension soit en
détention avec - décentralisée il faut
faire monter la tension que l'on va vous
injectez et une fois que vous avez
rejeté parce que sinon c'est pas des
plus et si vous commencez engagés à
rejeter l'opa soit son avenir en france
à combler dans certains endroits parce
que justement ça fait trop monter la
tension du réseau et à ce moment une
partie des moyens qui sont pied
d'égalité l'espagne donc le bal face le
volet comprend mieux ce grand jean doit
être compatible avec une société en
résistance structurelle et je pense que
ce qu'il propose
c'est justement quelque chose qui
correspond à une société
le voir
c'est bien
non
sans changer les contraintes de temps
sur vos raisons